okay are we are we live nope
now three two one
hey what's up people what's going on
you know the drill you know the drill
let us know all the things
how's it going guys hit that like button
if you're here we are going to talk
about thor love and thunder we got coy
here no spoilers what was the thumb up
for spoilers was the finger up for
spoilers i touched did you do i touched
my face oh he touched his face no
ulterior purposes and no significance
and uh it's spoiler filled thor love and
thunder live stream and we only got koi
here for like
about two hours two hours is that us
that's uh we're on the team we wanted to
hear the delayed playback so that way i
could just make it really difficult for
us now we know it is us and if you guys
can hear us that would be very
just just let us know you can hear we
could hear us because we're
experimenting here with this new road
caster
and also um i want to thank elgato for
hooking up some lights and um we finally
got a stream deck let's see what fancy
things john can do in the middle
ooh what can you do john oh i can make
this
oh that's cool i can make the super
chats come up oh my god
turn the lights out oh
oh nice i can do a bunch of other can
you make us monochromatic whenever we
talk about gore that'd be nice do you
have the time john i can figure that all
out
right now
immediately live on
let me add a function and i can turn us
very blue oh that's cool he's over here
being the rizza
of the internet mixing sampling live all
right quick mansions that's right let's
get focused since we only got a couple
hours here with mr comic book boy over
here um so uh i i saw how many times
have you seen thor 11 thunder thrice
three times
we saw it twice you've seen it twice uh
fascinating experience and why don't we
give our second view and go around and
guys in the chat why don't you tell us
what you guys think about the movie be
honest i know it's a solid 100 for
everybody everybody everybody's on the
same page they're all like
perfect balance of comedy from beginning
to end yeah everyone's saying that
um so
john why don't you go first i really
liked the movie both times i i the
second time just smoothed it out i mean
yeah there are aspects of people's
complaints that i can certainly
understand and agree with but uh for the
most part
uh yeah for the most part uh yeah it got
smoother and more enjoyable
and uh it's uh it was one of the like i
said i come out of a lot of marvel
movies thinking either like oh i like
that or or oh that was really cool but
this was one where i was like yeah man i
think i kind of love that and i still
maintain that so
i like what it's about and i like who's
involved and all that stuff
well uh the the second time watch i put
out even a tweet um before when the
reviews are popping like wow i really
disagree with a a lot of i haven't i
didn't actually listen to anyone's full
review i kind of just went through some
capsules heard some like ran the only
actual full review i listened to was dan
merles just because it popped up and i
was like sure i'll listen to this
and i was like nah i just don't i don't
feel that way about it and the second
time we watched it that um it wasn't as
packed of a theater so i was able to
really just take it in
and
i did find myself going this first half
of the movie is not quite clicking for
me
anywhere near as much as it did the
first i think the first time around i
just found it
so much more fun in that first half but
on my re-watch i was like oh you know
now that i've experienced these jokes it
i i do start to feel some moments are
like this is moving by really quick
these jokes are are like
so sketch comedy like sometimes that
they're not quite it really hit me
especially in the lady sif moment yeah
that's when my
impression started to really change on
the movie i'm like oh now i'm really
feeling it was because the first time i
saw that ladies sift scene i thought it
was really funny
and then the second time i was like
yeah i don't know now that i've already
laughed at this i don't really like this
scene anymore and
but the second half of the movie i like
i still like quite a bit i i really like
the second half of the movie still holds
up pretty strong for me
and the duality gets bigger between each
viewing for me like the separation of
quality of my experience between the
first half and the second half grows
each feeling yeah yeah because i i think
what dawned on me
what and i found myself wanting to
research i say this in the car ride back
with john
uh what i was saying um in the uh what
what dawned on me when with the moment
with the kids and then being aware that
taiko ytd's kids weren't at christian
bale's kids and and even chris hemsworth
kid obviously it it hit me like i feel
like taiko ytd this time around even
though it has scenes that are so much
darker than ragnarok
when it is focusing more on the love
themes i think he wanted to make like a
family movie it felt like a family movie
oh yeah i just i just realized this was
spoilers in this moment it felt more
like in this actual moment it felt more
in common with shazam to me than
anything in the mcu and i love shazam
but i don't think it quite landed some
of the themes that shazam landed as well
so like at the end when he gives his
powers and shares them with the kids and
i've seen some people call that a plot
hole to me i rationalize that as like he
could share his powers with his
guardians so maybe like that's how he
hasn't been able to do that before why
he hasn't done that before anyway the
fact that i'm already like well he does
it with uh
thunderbolt with thunderbolt which is
not when he abused them with the power
of thor who's thunderbolt in this in
this sense i think i'm thunderbolt ross
my brain is not oh sorry uh zeus
miss naming zeus zeus lightning bolt oh
oh oh no you're totally right but my
brain just wasn't i was thinking about
ross and i was like was he here uh yeah
but like uh that is a really good point
like so there is a tool to spread the
thing and i thought it was really cool
to make that moment about family and
about kids and like you know the
directors of father the leads the father
the the the you know jane's a father
jane's a father uh natalie portman's a
mother like everyone here has kids so it
kind of makes sense that we're at that
age where they start making these for
families
but i don't know if people were prepared
for that like i don't know if that's
what the audience wanted so i don't know
if that's why the rotten tomato score is
so low i don't know if that's what the
expectations didn't meet i don't know if
it really comes down to that i think
i think on the second viewing
normally by the way guys can you clarify
for us our do our mics because we have
two inputs here we have the volume for
our headphones and then we have the
microphones and so
to us we sound loud but i don't know if
our volume actually sounds okay on your
guys's end so can you guys clarify for
us if the volume actually sounds all
right that we have no stare in our head
we don't know there's no snare i need
like i i i feel like when i walked out i
was like yeah it's like an eight for me
on my second viewing it actually went
down to about a seven for me oh full
yeah about a seven to a seven and a half
somewhere somewhere there i would say
it's still but i still feel like there's
so much to really love about it i love
uh christian bale's performance and i
think the visuals are still really
dynamite like they're super i i didn't
know this until yesterday last night
late at night that they shot it with the
volume technology yeah and i thought
like oh that's so cool
and i really like i don't know i really
like chris hemsworth you know the thing
with uh that it is that first half
that's just a little bit clunky to me
because on my first time viewing it even
with all the comedy i could still really
feel the melancholic undertones like
take the
the breakups montage
of watching jane and thor's relationship
i really enjoyed that stuff like i
really really like that and that's in
the part of the first half of the movie
and um i felt more of those like
underlying melancholic tones a little
bit more even throughout and i felt like
but i don't know i i there's something
about it but we'll dive more into it we
got to get more specific and stuff here
yeah i just uh i just just talking to
john i think it's the highest of my like
third tier in marvel like i've got my uh
like s t or like the stuff that's
perfect and those are like six or seven
movies that i think like no notes no
changes holy crap any of my top seven
could kind of alternate to my number one
spot and then there's the stuff that i
think is absolutely just powerful and
incredible i can re-watch and that kind
of like and i know this is controversial
and i'm gonna get crap but like iron man
3 is the end of my perfect like a's not
quite like b's but like a a minus i
think this is the top of that third
section like this is the top of my
middle ground
marvel like it's still bees they're
still enjoyable but it doesn't quite hit
for me but it's the top of that i
actually put this right above uh
ragnarok for me oh really huh
i think i like uh ezra is asking in the
chat i think i like rag i think
ragnarok's a more
i mean i know you're not a big you're
not the biggest ragnarok fan i feel like
that's a more solid more more consistent
in what it actually is executing the b
well this is a teaser for another koi's
comic corner but we're gonna be doing a
ranking and this is uh just for this
section but it's gonna be for me this
moon night in ragnarok but we'll talk
about that in length next week sometime
but we will not overshadow john's love
for this movie or his thunder for this
movie or thunder he was filled with the
thunderbolts honest um so honesty yeah
good
um but yeah still a bee for me um like i
i definitely consider this better than a
lot of other comic movies and i
definitely like enjoyed my experience
with it but yeah there are things that i
have problems with i just like i i don't
care about those as much as how much fun
i had like i was really happy see i feel
like people a lot of people in the chat
have been saying too much comedy and and
i really felt like that was only in the
first half of the movie yeah like the
too much comedy part that only really
hit me especially on a re-watch where
i'm like
99 of these jokes are just not that
funny the second time around like i mean
if it's not 43 the first time around
sorry it's not good i'd like to see it
really you're gonna like it
but the second time watching i was like
yeah this is not starting to feel like
punch lines all the time
where's the first time it really
really made me laugh a lot the first
time but the second time i was like oh
no these aren't really working for me i
mean it's kind of hard to expect that
out of the comedy bits yeah i don't
really watch
like i in general you got to watch you
got them
like yeah you got to like
come back and this might be great in
like five years you know when you come
and revisit it now that i've seen it
three times i'm probably good but like
revisiting it uh in you know another
rewatch and it's it's certainly the one
that i am most excited like i don't have
kids yet but i want them it's one that
i'm really excited to share with not yet
existing children and the cast and crew
seem really you can tell when like
people [ __ ] in interviews and and i
feel like
they they're not they had the best time
that was the most really enjoyed in this
movie i think kevin feige was so happy
to have them have fun and i think they
were all so happy
but the comedy still works for you
strongly well no i mean it it worked for
me or it didn't pale partly because this
was one of the marvel movies where i
felt like they weren't so much writing
just punch lines as they were writing at
least jokes in character so i was like
even if it's not as funny the second
time it's still in character so i don't
mind that as just dialogue
that's intended for humor so it didn't
really i also think i actually didn't
expect this movie to be great
i i felt like really i expected not to
like it as much as ragnarok and i
expected i don't know like it's been
interesting to watch tyka uh you know
crest into
you know stardom
and uh and yeah for whatever reason
going in i just didn't have as much
faith that it would uh wow me or do
something new or take me to a place i
wasn't expecting and i'm i it did so i
think i'm coming from the other place
and that's maybe why i put ragnarok a
little lower is because i
was expecting something that i didn't
get from ragnarok and i was a little i
was a little upset that i didn't get the
same experience of ragnarok as everyone
else because i saw ragnarok uh you know
a couple weeks early and then i then the
the uproar of fandom was like this is
the best movie ever and i saw it again
and i was like i didn't get that either
time so i think my disappointment of my
overall ragnarok experience colors even
my rewatches of it so i think maybe
since my expectations were too high for
ragnarok and they were lower for love
and thunder i got more out of this movie
because i was like i know what i'm
getting this time fascinating it's funny
comic fans i know and you included
were the ones at the time who were like
i don't care for this ragnarok movie
well it's just so tricky because i think
that the best and what ragnarok did give
me is it gave me i think the best thor
in the mcu in in game and infinity war i
think what the russo brothers were able
to do balancing tychus thor and the uh
kenneth branagh and uh alan taylor thor
in those scenes with rocket in those
moments of melancholy and even fat thor
those moments of pathos and those
moments of comedy at the cost of this
man going on a journey to figure out who
he is i think are the best thor even i
actually like those thor moments more
than comic thor but the problem is when
you swing back to full you know comedy
it's really hard to have that work for
me as comparing it to where this exists
in the mcu yeah and we talked right
before air that like it does feel like
it's a protective layer for him uh it's
really about him trying to you know like
keep people out and keep people distant
joke jokes there's a lot of levels
i wanted to see a little bit more of the
underneath the front
sure sure quick aside king dingling uh i
did notice how many times the word [ __ ]
was used in this movie and it did feel
like i was back in some kind of 90s
pg-13 scenario where i was like oh i'm
not used to hearing so much [ __ ] in
march the s-word do we have any super
chats queued up we have so many super
chat hit up guys let's look i think the
general consensus is like yeah the the
first half is
looking at the looking at the chat you
have that you have the chat right in
front of us and looking at the chat and
it seems like the
the first half is people are generally
like the most likely
yeah that's the most mixed part for
people is the first half for sure
i uh well and someone didn't like see
it's funny the last five minutes of this
are amongst my favorite five minutes of
the mcu and someone just said the last
10 minutes was cringy not that i
generally listened to people that used
the word cringe but uh i i think that
the last five minutes was like using the
title as like a landing and also like
that moment of fatherhood and him like
he was seeking love since thor won he's
been wanting love and now he has the
love of his daughter and like that
that's really special uh so i love the
last five minutes well i mean the movie
sets you up that's the whole
i think tycho more than ever just went
like i really feel like he made a family
comic
it's like a family comedy or a really
dark sci-fi movie
he really he really does it's like it is
like the love inside and so in some ways
i like the concept of that the construct
because you do get the a bombastic
version of both yeah you know uh love
comedy and then thunder where it gets
like really dark when you're focused on
gore um but i did want more but i did oh
yeah i think more gore and especially uh
more butchering would have
that way you were really feeling the
stakes that zeus didn't feel yes exactly
um and you know what uh i i what do you
guys think about zeus in the chat in the
chat songs because even on my rewatch i
was like
i like russell crowe's performance
i know it's a real as someone says zeus
is so corny i know it's a real hit and
miss
that's such a divide with people but i
liked russell chris that was things that
worked for me and i think there are two
ver there's like
two versions of gods that i've always
heard portrayed it is like the more
snotty flamboyant like that's kind of
the versions that are captured here
yeah just puts his dick in stuff and
then there's they are boisterous then
there's zacherus
yeah yeah exactly they're not all
they're not all noble yeah it's like i i
like the zack snyder edge i like that
for abercrombie but then no that's not
the myths but i think for this version i
was like no i like this especially for
the argument of like what is the purpose
of you guys are not the [ __ ] you know
agreed so yeah i liked i liked the uh
the russell per tail i thought it was
really and i think
one of the things that made me laugh
again for some reason it's such an easy
cheap bit but when he walks down the
steps
i don't know why it's funny the casting
is a huge part of that too russell chris
oh
true very true very true and i do get a
kick out of his greek accent oh it's so
thick and hilarious i love it it's like
being back at greek wedding audrey
saying sir says the scene and the gods
reminded me of the dog scene in the lego
movie i couldn't stop laughing because
that's all i thought of that's a great
call i do like also when he's like
soccer ball yeah just loves himself
i don't want to say none of the jokes
work for me again in the in the re-watch
i think everything with um
with uh what you may call it uh milner
and um i still i'm always questionable
how i pronounce that
the only near and uh and uh stormbreaker
i still like i think that bit oh yeah i
don't know how you guys feel about those
comedy bits but i i felt it i like the
comedy of that a lot of people are
arguing against the orgy jokes i do not
understand how much gods talk about
origins oh my god the gods and how many
orgies there are in mythology there is
there's an orgy a week and frankly the
fact that we didn't even see an orgy is
only because the rating we got quite a
bit of super chats don't we yeah i've
been seeing them piling and we should uh
definitely we're ready to go all right
jb bonafis uh bonifacio calling it now
hercules and cleo will eventually
replace thor and doctor strange
wait where are you at where are you
reading this i am reading it right here
oh that's a cool little screen you can
read it here yeah i can see it it's
right there
oh yeah yeah that's right
straight ahead oh yeah hercules will
replace thor doctor strange
i don't know if i want to see that
i think
i don't i don't want to see solo-led
movies for them i'm not sure about that
i personally think that that we're going
to get brett goldstein for a couple
movies and i personally think we're
going to clear for a movie could be
wrong
i'm not that excited about clea to be
totally frank i also just don't know how
much you know charlize's want to commit
to a franchise like i can't see her
being like i'mma do nine of these like
doctor strange is in way more movies
than you realize that dude is everywhere
so i i can't imagine clia taking that
spot personally i think charlie stern is
uh when she's in a drama i am so excited
and yeah she's amazing as furiosa i even
like her in comedy long shot yeah
actually i don't know what i think i
literally convinced myself you just like
wrote yourself around your life
because i was like come to think of it i
like her pretty much everything comedy
and action you know she is versatile
this charlize theron's going places i
even randomly what's that seth rogan
comedy that's long shot that's what
that's long that's what it's called
it's so funny so slept on it thank you
so
yeah and that's like it's just a
straightforward comedy greg is excited
for clea to be in the blog i feel like
you know especially when you only have
like 10 seconds of
there's there's an unfair uh impression
you got to make yeah in that short
amount of time i did i was not a fan of
that post credit scene uh with clea so i
think that has a lot to do with it these
two post credit scenes for me were like
three times better than the two dogs i
mean the hercules the hercules entrance
was like you guys from ted lassa right i
do not he does i was so i mean we were
together yeah
but like that was actually an incredibly
gratifying moment to finally have
something in the mcu to be sitting there
and especially sitting next to you and
then to to have that mutual like oh my
god like that felt like the phase one
moments like me and john going like it's
happening it's actually happening i
never would have thought but this is
perfect oh thank you jb pelvin meyer
says god gasm i want it yes
shelby i've always tried to i've seen
the movie twice now in dolby at amc and
loved it
but i cried so much
uh
nicole was right heartbreak does feel
good in a place like this
[Laughter]
did they play nicole kidman yesterday it
didn't seem like they did did you not
get nicole they didn't give us nicole
when you're at amc you get a refund
right now and i'm actually i've seen you
get a reason i completely missed i mean
you're on tick tock a lot i am so you're
you um
tick tock does a lot of uh comic book
related videos by the way links in the
description um i'm in the main culture
the one i forget what movie it was that
we saw but when the crowd started losing
their [ __ ] at nicole kidman i was like
what i don't understand what's happening
right now
it hasn't become an unstoppable meme to
the point where people uh
there's some remember what i might buy
you should and i
one of the last times i saw it the
audience was like participating along
that's how i know i'm in the right
audience if it's a comedy because they
get the nicole lines kevin lopez is uh
pretty much echoing some of the things
that you said in your video about uh
hercules will be thor's rival eventually
bro just like in the comics and join the
avengers while cleo become strange's
wife and become sorcerers check out the
video we just dropped two days ago
corners appreciate the super chats
people pandemic
um i will keep mine short and sweet uh
thank you pandemic another divisive mcu
movie that i loved christian bale was
fantastic what were your favorite
moments goats screaming after crashing
the planet was great well i'm sure we'll
be going through a lot of our favorite
moments as we do this but i don't want
to talk about anything i liked
i think i think let's talk about the
goats while we're here ah i
thought the goats
were hilarious i laughed every time and
i'm not usually that kind of family guy
humor i laughed everything at the
premiere there was a few people who were
like i [ __ ] hated them it was
i think they're maybe the most divisive
thing in the movie is people either hate
or love those guys i expected to hate
them the second they showed i was like i
know the screaming goat meme and and
yeah it was it was funny me each time
but i know and then in the second
viewing i was just like okay this is
just a part of the movie now i'm not
this part of the soundtrack when they
like when they crash into the showers
planet and they just hear the screen
from far away i'm like i love it that
whole thing and i love that they chose
to make the planet like a just a
asteroid just like a tiny little
asteroid that you can walk around yeah
it's good like
gravity the demon planets like the
demons that come out of the planet you
can see it like enveloping the the
surface is so red
kundu wants to know uh you know why kill
the god butcher did you have an issue
with that any anybody
because like he's such a good character
but uh i felt like his end here was
pretty fitting yeah i don't think the
the bringing uh i don't think the end
works without killing him because that's
all about the daughter that's all about
the things they set up i think it's
necessary so usually it does bother me
when they just do one and done villains
but this one worked for me
pandemic you followed it up you said you
wanted to keep it short you're a liar
you're a great liar super chat liar
natalie portman said there was one of
the most visual i i i was watching the
interview of the of the cast and crew or
just cast and tycho um and they said
this too i was like what scene was that
natalie portman said it was one of the
most visually beautiful scenes she has
seen on film and they filmed it in a
best buy parking lot parking lot what
scene do you think that might be i
thought there were a lot of beautiful
shots i have no clue what's one thing to
do in glendale yeah the uh christian
bale so i was yeah
i was like i go to that best friend and
i i don't know is it the eternity scene
i i couldn't quite think of it i think
it's the alternative scene because they
shoot the attorney scene with all that
water
in and i think they literally in the
parking lot green screen cube oh okay
they just walked into it and then they
just mapped it what a random area
and they probably could spread out
enough to get some kind of scope of the
floor with a lip that they could put a
thin layer of water on to because the
pandemic was like they needed that like
rent spaces out sure maybe maybe they
literally were all right best buys
available yeah if you guys didn't know
that apparently there's some scene that
they they filmed the glendale parking
lot and best spot glendale but he got
natalie's number hit her up ask her like
damn that's that's wild like i mean yes
and then to know that when we say filmed
on volume that's like the mandalorian
technology where you actually have like
the sets built like there's a screen
around you yeah so a lot of times in
marvel what they'll do because i even
know it's in the trailer when he does
that big ending shot they would use
that's from the beginning in the movie
when they're fighting those like
uh jim henson like yeah that they the
colors
wildly different in the trailer it's all
blue and dark and uh so normally what
they do is in post-production they use
green screen right and they fill it in
later but here they they had to do most
of it in advance so it's very different
for a marvel movie to do that immersive
nash
mcu phase four let's redeem all villains
it's also therapy phase every hero's
going through therapy and every villain
is getting some redemption well i think
it's it's a more naturalistic approach
to reality right like no one thinks
they're a villain no one goes into a
scenario like this is evil but in this
situation we're getting the time to
flesh out why these characters feel this
way so i think phase four is more about
fixing phase one's problem where the
villain was just like what if the hero
was the same but bad like every villain
had that problem now we're getting some
nuance and i think that's that makes it
strong i think it started happening with
killmonger and thanos yeah that's ending
phase three i think they just learned
that lesson they were like people like
when our villains have more depth
kingpin and daredevil have an
interesting relationship what do you
know when they kind of mirror some of
the protagonists people like this
because yeah gore storyline um so
investing it's it i think gore storyline
in many ways is reflective of both jane
foster and thor's i agree and i really
love that they were able to land that
and it's and it's one of the most i
think relevant questions uh an mcu movie
has brought up period true i agree and
as as an agnostic it was really
interesting to see uh them handle
religion failing head-on
so uh thank you nash uh johnny why don't
you read cutter thank you cutter cut her
hail
been a fan of y'all since i was 11 and
now i'm 22 almost 23. christ the lord
lord hear that long goddamn dang thanks
for all the great content man's life
movie was fun going to see it again
today and tomorrow well i'm glad you had
a good time and hey thanks thank you
that's incredible thank you for sticking
around happy able to drink i like
reading some positive comments and thank
you for watching us for for so long
there are few places i there are a few
channels i've watched
i feel like i feel like this channel
didn't really start until like 2014.
that was like eight years ago now and
that's when it really started out so
maybe they watched your do something
yeah yeah so i was like oh now
something's finally paying off with this
yeah maybe they're just not good at math
maybe cutter needs math i think some
people might be i think cutter just went
there and was like what's the oldest
upload here i'm gonna check that i've
been a fan
oh no i'm just messing with you jimx
mafia
after my own heart i think jane
whispered it's morbid time into thor's
ear that is the best catchphrase yet the
morbid times more because the more the
thing is what do you guys think about
the film from sony morby is the living
now what did you guys think about not
revealing the catchphrase a plus good
good call i loved it i think uh there's
nothing that could have lived up to that
moment i thought she nailed it on the uh
eat my hammer part i wanted it and it's
hammered well and that's why i think
that i think it's because that works
well and that's the actual moment where
she triumphantly delivers a catchphrase
and then
you know then you can fill in the blank
of maybe it's a silly one and he's being
loving or maybe it isn't good
yeah i wanted to stop it's hammer time
but like here we are nothing's beat free
guy
when he goes
catch
catchphrase
as a catchphrase is a pretty cool
catchphrase
which watching free guy again i liked
tyka better the second time which he was
initially my my least favorite part of
that movie which i was initially bummed
by i really like free guy a lot but i
like him more though the more i watch it
dakota jones hey buddy thank you virus
fx
um hey guys haven't seen thor yet well
stick around uh
but just wanted to stop by and say hey
and one virus effects is my new
instagram my main got hacked but seeing
thor today we will make sure to give you
a follow there buddy thank you dakota
for roy thor popping in here just for
support michael mack looks like from
reading previewing this cool you're
going to want to read that one i wasn't
sure the first feeling but clicked the
second time it was great fun big love to
you guys as always from scotland loving
koi's comic corner two i appreciate you
from scotland and from here uh thank you
man i have been loving doing that show
and it has been a wild time to see all
the comments like you guys have been so
supportive i was legitimately afraid
because this little like network of
reject nation is very passionate and
proud and i was so afraid of like just
being like here's some nerd [ __ ] but you
guys have been incredibly receptive we
don't like nerd [ __ ] here not here at
reject nation
but i literally i'm in the first video
without you guys that's terrifying i
like sat down like i'm in the chair no
it was all part of the plan
long game we played really a plan it
really was like coy your first one i'll
be here with you and then i won't know
what to say so that'll be good john will
be here john be there and our point is
just to ask you questions and now i'm
just doing that but off camera yeah
and then you're there on the corner
going it's been 27 minutes see the sad
thing slow down start this again you got
to explain what this is you know you got
to talk about this what's the
singularity see the sad thing is the
point is for you just to to fly and be
your own little birdie but that
wolverine was so fun i was like oh i
wish i could just be the idiot for all
of this can i be the what's going on
guys
um especially too because when i hear
you guys filming through the wall i'm
like that sounds like the most they are
expect
nobody left this much during filming
there was one ron burgundy moment that
we'll never see the light of day of
something coy said
that was just the most we've left
i like it brought me to tears but
because koi just read something i put
down and uh
we enjoy filming that show too it's
either a ron burgundy or joe biden woman
whatever you want to look at whichever
way you want to lean tin end of quote
read life did i see that
it's like
this is
you guys gotta watch it that joe biden
moment that was so funny
oh god history books this is a weird
timeline tins i think a gore thank you
for your for your contribution by the
way pretty very much appreciate it uh i
think gore should have been a stronger
foe i wish they would have shown gore
crash the meeting with all the gods and
butcher a whole bunch of them to make
gore really seem extremely powerful we
definitely needed some more scenes i
think we needed some scenes the things
they cut
yeah we keep hearing about it like it's
funny usually in interviews everyone's
so cagey but christian bill's out there
like yeah i killed this person and this
person and this happened
and then like and then uh hemsworth's
like my kids are in it and they gave me
the last five minutes of the movie he's
like my daughter's in it named love i
was like what are you doing
i always say that
when um uh yeah because christian bale
was doing and he was saying he said
several times in interviews now and this
is the most i've ever watched press for
a movie and like post watching a film
and he was saying that the first three
days he was on set
he they were just tied up and he was
just monologuing a lot yeah and uh a lot
of it was taika ytd suggestions a lot of
it was his own improvisation and a lot
of it was just great everyone was like
yeah it was terrifying but
apparently
like none of that's in the magazine
once and we're talking about the the
vines scene i think i that might be
because i love that scene i love that
that wasn't tied up but he's talking
about that no no he's saying they're
type their title oh god he's monologuing
but no apparently there is more violence
and and a lot of
but no that i think they just
drastically trimmed that down i guess a
lot i felt that a lot i felt that
especially in the scene with the kids
yeah kind of just ends that scene when
he cuts off his head literally when he's
when he says that's why you're here and
then they cut away i was like that seems
long there's way more terrifying
children in the cage i do i do wonder if
there's some type of reactionary effect
ever since eternals didn't do that great
for them where they're like we need to
shorten everything yeah like this is
literally as short as thor one like this
is a very short movie and i and i
definitely could have used some more
drama to balance the comedy of the first
time could he use like 20 more minutes
yeah i said the same thing about doctors
i wasn't
less so than doctor straight like it's
not a
detriment but it's one of those things
where i'm like i could watch this for 20
more minutes i also enjoyed this a lot
more than doctor strange i i there's
plenty of things i know that's kind of
the most controversial thing we'll say
today is i think all three of us
probably like prefer this over doctor
strange but there are things about
doctor strange that i definitely prefer
oh yeah i agree with that yeah there's
more moments in doctor strange that i
think support
the mcu and doctor strange itself the
dark gothic visuals and the violence and
i i really the montages man i loved it i
really did like
it ian schmidt jane foster actually said
it's thorben's time
and i'm all about that as well
ej get thor edge
[Music]
gore the god butcher only showed on
screen to kill one god how did you all
feel about that instead of showing more
also did you feel the comedy was
too much at times uh i mean we covered
this right at the beginning i know some
stuff we'll have to recap it's the
livestream uh i i think um
speaking for at least coy and i uh that
the first half was too much
it didn't feel that way the first time
around the second time around for sure
and then uh
yeah we wanted more what's interesting
is if you throw in 10 minutes or even 15
to the first half and add the drama that
i think they cut it would balance out
the too much comedy for me like it's not
that the comedy bothered me it's just
that i wanted to see more of i consider
what thor's doing a facade of like he's
so broke and he's using comedy as a
thing to keep people away like deadpool
does like deadpool uses comedy to keep
people at a distance to make people
think he's annoying thor is using comedy
to make himself seem dumb so he can seem
like more secure in his insecurity i'd
like to see that veil slip a little bit
i'd like to see like a little bit more
of who thor actually is hiding under the
comedy and i feel like that could have
been in the first half to make it
support the film
um absolutely well well i think well say
really fast is that i also really quick
is that
i think your opening scene
really sets the stage a lot for what an
audience is going to emotionally expect
when watching a film so if you compare
it to ragnarok whereas a lot of people
are saying like i just think ragnarok's
more balanced and i'm like i don't
really think of any dramatic scenes ever
from ragnar to be totally honest like i
don't really there's like one scene in
ragnarok where i'm like with odin
towards the end yeah good drama scene um
but most of the time i don't think about
those like the heartfelt stuff or the or
the emotional things because the opening
of ragnarok is really funny and exciting
whereas the opening of this movie is
very dark and dreary like the freaking
guy is stranded in the desert starts off
on a shadow and it's daughters
you know and then he stabs a god in the
in the throat so it's very dark and
violent and it's just a lot of jokes
like following that so it just sets the
stage entirely different for your
viewing experience because i think
ragnarok actually has more comedy than
this movie it's just the comedy i think
really stands out so much more here
because when there's heartfelt stuff
mixed in with a movie that just sets you
up for purely a comedy
it the heartfelt stuff um
kind of weaves in a little bit smoother
for some reason versus such a dark heavy
opening and then a bunch of comedy and i
think that's where some of the imbalance
can start to
be more apparent i think it also is the
most i've ever felt and edit i think
like in a marvel movie true true true
and i don't know if that's because of
how much they were more open in the
press but like i do think that would
like he asked if i'd like to see some
more butchering i would have
i don't know if that would have helped
the first half but i could have used
some butchering it becomes that thing of
uh you know you see it on screen you see
that little montage of them looking over
how many people have been butchered and
then you're here like oh
that's it true true but uh david gandy
david he got us a camera
i was reading the chat you're talking
the whole time looking clearly at your
reflection in the tv how are you doing
hi guys landed overall a solid movie for
me the experience for me was uneven but
averaged out good but not great
definitely an entertaining film i mean
as long as the movie's not boring it
generally gets my recommendations but
that's where i land i feel the spectacle
i feel the excitement i got those things
that's how if boring is the worst in
soul side i think the levels of insult
for film are boring is the top the
irishman annoying oh you sound a [ __ ]
i was literally thinking the other day i
was like you know i think i like
irishman more than heat
what the [ __ ]
i don't i'm not i don't i when i
eat i was like i don't like this as much
as i thought i did it oh my god i like
the irishman the first or second
quality movie i think i love irish cat
the irishman is so boring scorsese
[Laughter]
i think heat is michael mann's best and
scorsese's worst is not collateral is
100
all right we got a couple in the
streamlabs don't worry we're not cutting
i know there's more super chats there
we'll get to them yeah just had to uh
refresh them because we'd reach the top
um hey why don't you can you uh guys in
the chat why don't you give i see some
people have been giving their ratings i
see a lot of six out of tens here um in
the chat can you guys just start putting
down your um out of ten ranking for the
movie and then we'll like uh take a
quick peek over it
all right flev doran
love it was a good addition to the mcu
good adventure not really great but not
bad my only disappointment was gore i
had expectations for bale who acted it
uh great but the writing blew me away um
didn't blew me away i wouldn't rank him
even top three one-time villains in my
opinion and he goes on to say the comedy
was a little too much at points like
zeus juggling act was too much but the
goats which i also expected to be
annoying from the trailer were very
entertaining i lost it for one whole
minute after the after they hit the
planet and screamed
i would have been like shut that guy up
he's still laughing
we've moved on to
i bet that guy's name is why'd you throw
a stormbreaker out the window
see that joke was funny because it
worked i don't know some some of the
stuff really worked for me some of the
jokes really worked
we're building the i mean you you guys
can uh we can't talk there's nothing we
can't really can't read we got no
information
here we go all right i'll just not i'll
just not do that all right cool all you
have to do
a couple more uh options oh that's true
i need to add options it's good we got
but now we got we got people out okay
let's read through stiff's arm out of
ten yes andreas i agree stop
okay move this over here it was very old
youtube i saw that i agree it was very
oh gee youtube
we're gonna show everyone's i'm we're
still we've got a monitor like way at
the bottom here
okay so let's let's just let's just kind
of go off brain here there's every
rating seven eight and a half ten out of
ten
ten four ten that compensates for the
ten five out of ten nine out of ten six
out of ten zeus seven out
wow that's like all over the place guys
that's crazy
uh kirti yes that is singularity i think
uh that is that is who i think she's
gonna be in the young avengers check out
koi's comic corner to hear more about
that theory
john how do i do this
oh damn that's cool tech just yeah oh
sweet look at that
oh wow
yes
oh i love it john it's it's very fun
thank you elgato thank you elgato i said
elgato hook us up
we stream
keep giving [ __ ] to people who don't
stream elgato we stream we stream
yeah
actually i think the last time we were
here with coy he had not had coy's
comment corner no this is the first live
stream with his comic corner
yeah notice how much more brief i'm
being so i can explain it on koi's comic
and now you don't want to talk in these
streams yeah i gotta save it from my own
channel corner where did we leave off
here david gandy here i got it
wait oh there's ways to like refresh it
which i personally didn't like this
movie because they made thornton okay
why don't you guys talk while i'm doing
this
where's the mcdonald's i don't know what
that means do you guys think
that
they don't know what to do with thor
anymore because i've been hearing that a
lot where they feel like people are
feeling like they don't really they're
not entirely sure what
mcu might be losing track of what to do
with the character
the complaint i keep hearing is that he
is been characterized inconsistently and
they keep making him a buffoon
and uh i could see that i mean i i felt
like here
[Music]
to me as a non-uh expert it's felt like
they have taken a sort of modular
approach to what thor's personality is
movie by movie and and
i guess luckily in my eyes the movies
have suited the approach they've taken
so it's okay with me
but i would be curious to hear koi's
thoughts really i think the character in
the comics is so tricky to nail down
even in the comic books because you're
adapting a norse god into comics so
you've got mythology you've got comic
lore you've got different sensibilities
whether it's the ultimate line where he
might or might not be crazy and then
they have to establish that you've got
the donald blake stuff you've also got
70 years of comic lore so i do think
that you can consider this a a
adaptation of some of the comics but
there's just so many years of comics
like walter simonson's thor is very
serious donnie kate's thoughts very
serious so i i personally saw the humor
in the kenneth branagh as more akin to
how i see thor more the fish out of
water more of the guy trying to figure
out what it is to be mortal in a world
of immortals and then reversing that so
that to me is more my sensibility but
i don't think they've lost the thread i
just think they see it as differently
than i do and that's not that's not on
them so um i just think they found out
chris hemsworth is a comedy genius and
like they were like let's use this
comedic genius we hired and then let's
get taika i don't think he was signed on
for a thor for i think he was willing to
come back because they let him play so i
think more thor is better than no thor
fair enough man fair enough you know
what i really want guys is a valkyrie
movie oh god i love her sorry i'm
watching her again here i was watching
it i've never seen an interview with
tessa thompson she's the best and then i
i mean i'm american so i'm not the one
to be like oh my god that's amazing
but i could have sworn because i've been
watching westworld uh season two
and i forgot that she's in that show
and now and i know she's in like creed
and stuff so i was watching
interviews with her and i was like
oh [ __ ] she's american yeah i thought
she was british because she's so
talented yeah
yeah she's in rad dude yeah i had no i
thought she was playing americans in in
stuff like creed and westworld oh she's
legit
i love her even though they don't give
her character too much to do like what
she does with what they give her yeah i
mean i i love her presence i think her
presence weirdly spoke more to me here
because of the fact that the writing
didn't give her as much but whenever she
was on screen
i loved when she's my favorite character
in the movie i i really was this was the
movie that made me go don't do a disney
plush show
give her a movie give her a movie
because i think she could hold one king
valkyrie i don't think she can hold one
um aiden n.y.r thank you
um
i wish gore had more screen time how can
you make a movie with gore the god
butcher and he only has
one on-screen kill oh my god is that
true just one yeah and it's the opening
just one i didn't even realize that
there's only one see him actually merc
one opening clearing yeah yeah but when
star-lord yeah he's right no one's
talked about the guard if you want to
know what i thought was the most
disappointing was the use of the
guardians i felt like tycho was like
this is perfunctory they left me with
them so i gotta have them but they they
hold nope they almost hold no pressure
well they literally like are looking up
an admiration at thor but like that's
not how we left them and we didn't get
any moments of comedy to get to that
point yeah i thought i thought he was
gonna be sarcastic they were so
i thought they were pretty wasted and
they're the guardians like i was like
when the first time i watched i was like
yeah they're fine because i was more but
then the second time i was like man
they're really wasted in this movie yeah
because they're hilarious
yeah but they make no impression i i
think i mean that goats was funny with
an introduction with him in the ship but
that was also more like you know spatial
humor yeah
darth the pooh johnny cancer is tough to
watch and the final post credit made the
movie for me i've lost too many to
cancer and the last scene made me quite
emotional but happy that finally a
character with cancer won in a movie
it's an interest that's a very
interesting and thoughtful point
that is very yeah i mean it is like a
fantasy fulfillment but it's funny i
don't want to get into too many spoilers
but
and it's not the same kind of thing
i've heard
uh
debates about a certain very prominent
death on a very uh huge television show
not the same exact kind of thing but
sort of a a a
a mishandling as the opinion i was
reading put it of you know many people's
experience and so here you know many
people experience the horrific effects
of cancer and so yeah i have to imagine
it is rare because so many movies
probably are trying to come at you with
the you know the fragility of life and
all the things that are absolutely valid
and legitimate but yeah to have that
catharsis of like oh she makes it to the
next realm you know and and can sort of
have
a benevolent and happy end you're like
yeah i think that's that's pretty
beautiful especially if if it's been
that close to your life yeah
thank you for sharing darth darth the
pooh that's i mean i've lost like
extended relatives to cancer so
but i've i know people who
have experienced a closer hand so it's
interesting hearing that because i've
heard the opposite with this movie that
some people thought like some of the
handling felt a tad bit
uh almost borderline offensive but i
didn't really no one really elaborated
on it whenever i've heard that i've only
heard that i'm not sure
but i obviously i don't have the direct
experience either so um i think because
maybe the movie it's in
because the movie is so jolly
i don't know i feel like they made a
joke out of it yeah that was one of the
things they didn't make a joke out of
they didn't make cancer funny no yeah
even in the first half whenever you
check in with jane it was still heavy
because i i mean for as much as folks
have valid complaints about the comedy
the second time to me especially it
started to reveal itself like when you
really cut to jane after that cut uh
with after that scene with darcy where
she's like ah it's fine i was like
there's so much in this movie that feels
like it's about the fronts people put up
to appear fine when they're
deteriorating or being deteriorated from
the inside true true um so yeah which i
thought also tied into um gore
beautifully i thought they handled that
really well yeah it was a nice parallel
quentin anthony anderson making it so
short i think heard it the most could
use 20 more minutes i agree your super
chat is also one of the shortest
comments
but we appreciate the brevity and we
agree with it i mean well i would say
too that with it being short i think
some things kind of get a little bit
lost upon people i think of one thing
that's been up for debate is the whole
thing about um thor with the lightning
uh you're instilling it to the kids yeah
because he used he he uses the
thunderbolt right to disperse it he's
not giving his own lightning
away he says the power of thor that's
what got confusing yeah yeah
and then says the power of thor to me i
took it as sort of like a he's got his
lightning power but it's also being
turbo charged by this additional god
weapon
but that's just me filling in the blanks
really well here we go aiden uh and also
yes shout out to axel he was cool he was
cool i liked his fur i liked his first
interaction with axel heimdelson
when he does project himself into the uh
actual cage
like randomly relevant things yeah that
are funny and dark
and at the end i was actually the one of
the parts that almost lost me the first
time was like oh kid army
but also then i thought well we live in
a time
where kids are put into these perilous
positions and he does empower them to
defend themselves yeah there was a
thought of like he's lost so many people
in battle would he put these kids in
danger but also like is there also the
need for these asgard
yeah like as guardians needing to be
prepared maybe that is a thing true yeah
thor loving comedy says alice and mello
in the chat
darcy was saying that
sarah williams and darcy's definitely
underused i mean she got her a lot in
one division and she like where else
would she have popped me too much darcy
yeah i mean
we'll see more of her yeah um aiden
higgins hey guys one of my issues with
this film is that this seems to be the
number one complaint i loved bayless
gore but i felt that i needed one to two
more scenes with him also that didn't
make him feel as much of a threat as he
should have in my opinion
i felt he was threatening and menacing
it it really just comes down to we
needed a scene where he killed some gods
instead of just coming to a screen of
like with the with the guardians being
like a bunch of gods are dying
i felt like they cut away from the
butchering of the gods and
literally two scenes would have changed
the whole thousand percent i completely
agree
um let's see here uh nev r williams
thank you thank you very much where
could you see hercules appearing next or
just waiting for thor five i think they
may still use enchantress at some point
love y'all that's a koi question
i think that thor will be uh going
through more of the fatherhood journey
and so we're gonna have hercules as kind
of what thor one's hercules was where
it's the i'm a noble god in this world
of peasants and why don't you worship me
and i think it's going to be really cool
to see the ark of thor reflected in
hercules you're going to see hercules as
what thor used to be meeting what thor
is today especially with that whole
paternal nature with his more caring
self so now that we've had the love and
the thunder we're gonna see what that
combines into when he's up opposite
someone that is like his old self i do
think enchantress would totally work for
that but i think as an antagonist
hercules gonna be really interesting
because his ego is gonna be his weakness
and i do think he's eventually going to
become a bit of an anti-hero or just
full-on avenger through time getting
humbled by thor and seeing what he could
grow into hmm that's a good answer
that's a lot of answer you read you you
queued me up greg i was ready to answer
man that's great jdl 1823 really quick
thank you because i was sitting there
going did they use november rain
so it's yeah i'm glad to know that uh
that was where that was i don't know
that song as well as the others but i
felt like they bought the the combo pack
of guns and roses songs and i was like
there's got to be a november reign
somewhere he really loves guns and roses
that tycoon you've been named a whole
movie
yeah literally posters in the background
it's the lead has named it sometimes you
hear a song in a trailer and you might
just hear one time in the movie but i
was like oh no this whole album yeah
they just guns and rose them up oniony i
love the relationship between thor and
his hammer
i do too i thought it was a very lovely
choice i mean you know the hammer the
axe they have
otherworldly properties anyway
give them a personality i thought that
was a fun twist and in the comics right
now uh odin is actually trapped in
mjolnir uh so odin dies and the odin
spirit gets trapped in the actual hammer
so thor hears the hammer as his father
kind of like criticizing him at all
times so he needs to wield this hammer
but it has the weight of the father
guilt so it's a really fun uh you know
wow yeah it's a lot it's happening
that's how they should bring back
anthony hopkins is anthony's the voice
of the old man yeah just like giving
thor [ __ ] all the come here dad but uh
yeah so i thought that was like you know
kind of a fun way to parallel those two
things having the love triangle be not
just with jane but with hammers
yeah yeah you know it's stuff like that
in the first half that was a little bit
weird to me on on the sec even the first
time i i saw that clip that when he goes
like come here boy and i thought it was
funny the first time i saw it
but then it hit me when i was watching
like he never once treated milner like
this in the other movies yeah
like a puppy like a pet
we're definitely ramping up like you
know if there's a taste of comedy like
him hanging mjolnir in dark world on the
coat rack now it's full on like calling
it like a puppy but the storm honestly
the storm breaker [ __ ] and it's when it
just comes in yeah i love when it just
like peeks around the corner it's well
worth physical confidence
yeah that was really really funny i i
think that's hilarious stuff
um
nash is back and i think chris
hemsworth's comedic ability to play off
of that
is also real that's a big part of what
makes it work when he's just like i
think that's what's conformed to these
movies yeah it is it isn't like that
they don't know what to do with them and
then chris hemsworth's like i'll come
back if you let me play he's just having
the time of his life i think it'd be
[ __ ] boring to be serious thor
honestly yeah unless maybe the writing
just needs to get better for the serious
store you know who's well roy clinton i
think it does create something of a
conundrum because you know like a swords
and sandals epic is different than what
you want out of a superhero rump or a
superhero action or something like that
so it is tricky
i do hope someone said uh if not a tight
cut we at least need a butcher cut if
there's more of the violent gore seems
to appease us all meg paul i would love
to see even deleted scenes out of
context just to know what we were gonna
rare is the occasion i go i hope there
are deleted scenes aplenty
nash sanadiki says zeus must must always
be portrayed by a british guy
well there's a classical vibe to it
isn't crow australian yep yeah but
they're saying like we can't have this
close enough we can't have this
australian greek man close enough
comedy
uh motorola
after the 87th ghost scream i was kind
of over the humor
overall though i did enjoy it i just
wish there was more from bail we get it
guys you guys he hate that there was not
much christian bale he is so you could i
just
watch him all day i completely get it
though and the look is great
yeah it's just amazing put him in the
movie have christian available like i i
so like this it's weird it's like his
portrayal is like the best case
scenarios like you know it doesn't seem
like christian bear really cares about
something like the mcu but like man is
it good to have him here well like
apparently his kids talked him into it
it was fun to see him having fun in a
comic book movie because he you know the
darkness he instilled in bruce wayne and
batman like the heaviness of that and
the hearing just seemed like he was
playing it didn't seem like uh in court
interviews that he was like staying in
character on set either yeah i think he
was just playing he was funny he said
like he would be uh like playing soccer
with his kids and [ __ ] like asgore yeah
and so i was like oh cause i i would
that would be one of my questions was
like did you stay in character like
because he's known to do that so i would
be curious to know if like do you stay
in character around he's like well i've
told you guys every time i've met
christian bale he's got a jolly energy
like christian bale is the most opposite
from the roles he plays of any actor
i've met because he is downright
jubilant he's a welsh dude that like
runs around giddy at every time i see
him every time we've met christian bale
we've thought the same thing
every every talk we have every
interaction every facetime call we have
a christian bale no but
it's a name drop worth noting for the
characterization like he uses his like
he channels this severity in this
intensity but regularly he's jolly like
i would compare him to santa claus
before patrick bateman like he's a
downright like holly jolly fella holly
jolly fella so i'm glad to see him get
to play that here
as vermont says christian pale good
good i still wanted him to be uh bitter
at bill that would have been cool like a
jolly gatorade bill like a welsh
remember that one shot in the trailer
everyone was like there's a third
character here that's missing it's been
cgi'd out oh yeah i do remember that and
there's nothing it was just a it's an
empty space
now they know how they're they're
playing into that also hello tube
russell's ellie chaya
team magic infinity thank you for the
super chat didn't like the ending
yeah [ __ ] that uh which which one which
ending uh the actual ending i'm
imagining
um could have been done better didn't
like gore going from evil to be redeemed
so quick
didn't feel earned to me it was kind of
odd that it was like
you
you mean you could have
you could have gone
know what no one ever told you that
i know but he was corrupted maybe like
the darkness he was corrupted by the
sword and the necro sword is destroyed
by that point so he has the clarity to
save his daughter so he's got the
clarity and also i mean it's funny i i
initially the first time i was like this
is gonna be lame with the whole like oh
he's gonna come around to love and it
didn't feel that way ultimately but the
second time it worked even better
because he's the one in the cave of
vines he's the one who says choose love
call the x like he brings that up as
a weird view of like what i'm doing is
loving in a way i'm creating peace for
people you know like he truly as a good
villain should believes in his mission
and believes that there is some aspect
of love in here and then finally at the
end
when thor turns and walks away
i did kind of believe the change because
i believed in the catharsis of like oh
this god isn't the same as every other
god and he's just gonna let leave me to
do as i wish while he goes and and
creates this mirror image to the very
start of the movie cradling you know
the same loss in his arms like i
believed the piercing of the veil in
them i i did really like that moment
yeah i didn't love the
talking talking oh i'm dying that line
really just came out of nowhere for me
he we assumed he was dying like we'd
been discussed it was dying so for in
mid monologue for him to do like an i'm
dying shakespeare moment did feel a
little off but otherwise the rest worked
for me
[Music]
fair fair jan mitchell
gore wasn't the villain the necro sword
was gore was the weapon that's an
interesting way to put that i like that
i do like that tape i don't
i like the take i don't i don't feel
it's a symbiosis
i think yeah it's a mutual bonding
i think it just further enhances that
true desire that he has
yeah
and and and you know enhances the
darkest parts you know sarah williamson
i forgot that chris hemsworth was
[ __ ] phenomenal in bad times the
elroy
terrifying he was doing such good
pregnancy he was so scary in that movie
he was dark brad pitt all day he was
scared i remember being in the theaters
being like this guy's terrifying i wish
i saw that in the theater
in theaters mr downtown hey r.r and coy
help me out here hey i'm a reject now
hey r r
including coy is what i should say send
another super chat and just fix it
help me out here didn't thor get
millionaire back in end game
uh with cap using it shouldn't there be
two millionaires chris evans took the
other one back to its timeline at the
end uh he brought the stones and then
the hammer back that's back in time yeah
boom yeah hammer time
boom
someone in the chat brought up earlier
how you know there seemed to be no
discrepancy yeah but between um storm
breaker and me on there and uh
and an end game yeah the battle
that's what i mean but something i don't
know i don't know i don't go there who
doesn't watch the movie being like put
it
different argument yeah that was an
extraordinary fight not a regular fight
yes
bobby quetzalcoatl
with thor for name dropping me w thor is
like win for thor like he did
for the kids and he said it funny
yeah he did what are you talking about
i'm confused he's talking all the gods
yeah he says quetzalcoatl at some point
oh yes
yeah when he's listing like zeus
quetzalcoatl all the although he said
hercules then that's why i was hopeful
i remember when those celestials were
showed in the trailers
i was like i bet it's just gonna be
they're just they're they're just there
and then they were and then they were
just there's a lot of like
oh my god what door does this open isn't
it uh and that's gonna be there don't
worry those two celestials will be in
guardians three according to coy's
theories which you can now view on the
newest koi's comic corner that went up
just before this i do think the
celestials are going to be important but
aren't yet and you'll see why because of
what john just discussed these are
important it'll all come together
yeah they froze that one and the earth
is fine they should have like an
afterlife the earth has not experienced
a field of read
a religious battle
it seems like it's kind of built into it
i mean with the gin and stuff disgusting
miss marvel
it's it's gonna be religious wars oh my
god that'll go over well
uh thor politics and religion
jaden
jaden bonnie where do you think thor
will go next will we get a thor five
from taika thor and guardians vol 3
somewhere else koi the comic expert
please tell us let me answer this one
you got this you got that
take it away
uh i don't think he's in guardians 3. i
think guardians 3 is going to be a
cosmic culmination of where we are
that's going to kind of
take out a lot of characters and lead us
to the thing that ties phase 4
altogether on the cosmic side i think on
the earthbound side young avengers and
thunderbolts are going to be the thing
that ties face for all together so i
think we're going to go back to kind of
the phase 2 where we've got cosmic and
earthbound being kind of separate so
thor i think is another thing entirely
where thor 5 i do believe is going to be
uh post young avengers and i do think
singularity might be a young avenger and
it'll be kind of a father-daughter
team-up thing and i do think that's
going to bring in hercules and kind of
the thing i was discussing with the
humility of a god and i think it'll deal
with all those power sets hold the phone
okay hold the phone
first off thank you everyone who's here
it's easy to forget how fun live
streaming is every time we don't you
tell me this every time we're so used to
so used to just filming and editing and
just not having the people to like
actually interact with everyone i'm like
oh this is fun
um
the
there's two people in the chat alejandra
and james who are saying daryl's in this
movie twice
when daryl's the tour guide in new
asgard and then that's oh my god that's
daryl oh he's got his name
that's there he does have a name
i didn't even think of it at the time i
didn't even that's the greatest easter
egg of all time
because it was like a character i didn't
notice the tint name tag oh no and then
and then valkyrie when she's walking
through the the families losing their
kids she assigns daryl a task she goes
daryl and she tells them to do a thing
i've been for the long i pitched this on
movie fights forever ago and i actually
won when they were when they were saying
pictures pitch a show for disney daryl's
in it and i was like do a daryl show and
where every episode there's a new member
from the mcu and he has to i thought it
would be like he could be working at
like avengers headquarters or something
like an employee
i'm like they're doing the show
yeah like you just have an episode where
it's always he's with some adventure
well it's gonna be a really fun show
daryl's in there office comedy show or
something like that the kind of hangout
show so oh damn he's a tour guide to
asgard for your show there you go like
oh my god this is coming towards what
i've been wanting is happening yeah that
makes me so happy so lovely i gotta i'll
go into it later i have a the weirdest
thing i noticed and i bet no breakdown
channels pointing this out oh [ __ ] i
have actually i'm going to do a a one
minute video for youtube about it i'm
not gonna say it now uh i i might just
for this just for the people here in the
chat i'll do a separate video i'll do a
separate one-minute video for everyone
in a minute uh but i'll tell you i don't
think anyone noticed this but i uh both
times i watch this movie i'm like why
did they do this
shot there's a very specific thing of
involving christian bale that every time
i watch this movie i'm like what a weird
choice and i don't think anyone's
noticing it
i know how to
yeah
you just gave us 30 seconds of the
minute a mild-mannered comic nerd i like
the movie but it did have too much
comedy in it till the middle i'm glad
we're on the same page i felt like i was
watching the matt damon and melissa
mccarthy extended show you see that bit
i thought went on a little too long for
my taste because the rest of the movie
felt so much like that bit like it
didn't the bit is funny because of how
ridiculous it is but the movie itself is
kind of operating in like that's like a
12 but the movie's at an 11 so it's like
not a big enough leap whereas in
ragnarok i felt like it worked because
it was so short that it was like oh
that's a good one note joke yeah i
actually liked the joke where they where
matt damon and chris's other brother
were talking and they were like we need
to make ah to the time like this to
bring the people like that to me was way
funnier
like that was way funnier to me than and
i just don't like melissa mcrae very
much i thought when like when melissa
mccarthy first
i thought it was really funny when she
first appeared the irishman's melissa
mccarthy
why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
no those are the yeah that's what i'm
saying [ __ ] yourself that'll improve
them both downtown who was lena heady
supposed to be eternity i don't think
was she supposed to be eternity i don't
think was ever going to be a character i
want to say she would have been like a
god in the vein of wonder woman i think
they would have made her like one of the
gods that gets killed
um i don't know the mythology of the
greeks enough to to guess to be honest
with you but that was my assumption she
was like look at lena heady she looks
like a goddess i would have cast her as
like a wonder woman stand-in she is hot
so she was supposed to be in and she
wasn't yeah and she got she got killed
she's getting a suit now and she's yeah
she's sued she's getting sued by her
management team in the uk for not paying
the dues that she was paid for this
movie
and we don't have managers do you pay
you have they get ten percent of
whatever but do you pay them directly or
i thought they i thought part of them
managing is they my money goes to them
and then i get 90 because they keep 10.
so they get 10 of my money that's why
i'm confused what did these managers do
so she's the uk manager so maybe she got
paid american was supposed to owe them
like maybe
you know the payroll in america yeah
yeah she didn't pay her you know
international one i i don't know lena so
that's just what i'm here call her up
koi all right on the telephone after
landon smith's i'm gonna reveal to you
guys i'm very curious what this weird
thing is i'm gonna tell you all about it
very excited does it have no i won't ask
why
does it have something to do with the
mole next to his eye yes did you notice
it too
yeah because he rolls over and it's like
you're directly facing that shot right
no that's not but it has something to do
with the mole honestly the tree look at
the intrigue
and
when i do the one minute video i'll
provide photos so i can show you
that i i believe i'm correct about this
landon smith
can't wait to see what brett goldstein
does with the hercules character part of
me just wants it to be roy cantus
hercules dropping f-bombs that's the one
thing as i was sitting here going damn
it they he won't be able to curse yeah
the entire show is about roy being able
to curse and now he won't how would how
would hercules distinguish himself from
thor from the first movie well that's
the thing is that thor in the first
movie was immediately trying to
get back home and through that he has to
prove himself worthy hercules doesn't
have to prove [ __ ] like hercules is like
already entitled he's the son of zeus
like he's gonna have he's gonna be like
malfoy and hercules put together like
he's a prick so he's not going to be
seeking redemption he's just like going
to be arrogant and herkulfoy yeah he's
going to be drinking and and oh my god
he's the guy someone in the i uh okay
someone pointed it he pointed out in the
chat
pg you got it there's one shot what
early in the movie when he's talk when
he's just regular gore
in the film they flipped the shot i did
because his mole is i forget which side
it's on because it's i don't know why
christian bale with the millions of
dollars he has has never gone in that
[ __ ] moe removed because it's it's
right there on his eye and every so
anytime he disappears into a character
and does all the crazy makeup i'm like
but that [ __ ] mold is so consistent
it's just right there blocking your eyes
so
um
yeah no like a couple people pointed out
they noticed it too
the shot is flipped for some reason
and it's just and they eventually cut
back to the same shot but it's normal so
that is the mold
this mole is just like on the other side
and i'm like what the [ __ ] why did they
flip the shot so maybe they needed the
shot flip through like visual effects i
have no idea why they would be on
it's when he's pleading and he thinks
he's been so
in the opening yeah he thinks he's it's
very early on in the movie and i noticed
i noticed it because i always look at
that [ __ ] ball so then the first in
the first movie in the first time i
watched it i noticed it i was like wait
a second like oh i thought his mom was
on the other side and then when it comes
down
i'm like it is on the other side that is
so interesting because yeah whenever i
watch the dark knight on imax i would
always look at the [ __ ] hole
russell movie which looks great and i'm
looking at all that crazy makeup and i'm
like my [ __ ] mole right so if tom
holland hadn't gotten rid of his for
spider-man he'd be like
yeah chop it up and make some guacamole
like robert de niro's it's him and
robert de niro both have these moles
that they've just never removed that is
just
gross maybe the deniro one i'm like i
get that that's part of your now it's
christian too apparent uh also will
terby thank you for the clarification i
hear lena headey was cast but never shot
her scene and the management still wants
their cut even though she wasn't paid
for not shooting her scene interesting
oh [ __ ] that never even shot the scene
if that's true a little understanding
you pricks yeah like i wrote the money
you weren't paid but yeah i was
expecting money
where is our imaginary money it's marvel
just being in a conversation with them
give me money
we are not privy to the inside track of
these conversations but that seems
sketchy my favorite detail pip pill
pie logan pie logan p logan that's what
i'm going with or pierre logan
take it away john 123 my favorite detail
is gore's daughter is played by
my chris hemsworth's real life daughter
i loved the ending and now it may be my
favorite in the mcu
it is amongst my favorite enemies
the pantheon of marvel
it is amongst my favorite endings uh i
thought it was really special i loved
the idea that the title is a landing and
um
they were adorable like i i you know i
again i don't have kids but the idea of
getting to act with your kid and
make these movies for your children and
put them in them is so special i know
this is like nepotism the film yeah
that's what it is oh they said too that
like the kids designed the berserkers
and stuff which which across the whole
film like brilliant wonderful i love the
use of shadow like the use of shadows is
like that effect where just all the
shadows grow and arms and legs start to
spread out like yeah it was genuinely
terrifying beautiful beautiful well i
think the ending is so beautiful because
the movie sets up in a very like
expeditory way love about how you know
thor keeps people at a distance because
he's been heartbroken so many times
he's longing for love and connection
and you know the movie's setting you up
that he's going to find it in the form
of romance and he finds love in a
different way and i think that's quite
beautiful how to do that it's and it's
unexpected honestly you know it's
[ __ ] the villain's daughter yeah i do
not expect that to be the landing after
like at any point in the movie until
they were in eternity and i was like oh
[ __ ] i know some people don't like it
and some people go woke they're giving
all our roles to the child and females
um male children is there really the
argument that them kids are taking our
jobs
kids take with their unlimited hours
can only work till 6 pm taking our jobs
[ __ ] a couple like 10 seconds in
total of of valkyrie what did she kiss a
girl on the cheek just like his
hands and then and then was that a
problem for [ __ ] and then
there's also uh they cut that stuff out
for china the what's her what's it
called uh
said something about the girlfriends
about your husbands
yeah there's like 10 seconds of gay
things and people are like shoving woke
[ __ ] in my face well and their gore says
like you know to to have lost the women
you love you know to valkyrie and all
right 15 seconds
if you guys can't handle hearing about
love
you shouldn't hear that's most of the
that's most of the people that are in
the chat by the way there are monsters
99 of our audience is the anti-woe
they hate anything don't watch my
content
sean costa says watch our stuff
john costas has put the kids back in the
cage
yeah yeah yeah we got aliens we got guys
naked xd says tired of being alone we'll
help you that's nice
[ __ ]
band this person please
which one the envelope is gonna are they
a real person or uh there's no way
they're real they've got jizz emojis
okay good all right uh
afb
[Music]
fv i think they should have ended with
making stuff about
oh oh from this
distance
about avengers vaginas and games after
end game now i think it's more of
quantity than quality but that's only my
opinion i don't know i mean i don't know
if it's really a quantity issue i think
the quantity issues in the form of we
had a pandemic and there's a lot of [ __ ]
stack that we couldn't release and so
it's all just kind of compounding and i
believe there's there has been quite
a uh
up he they're there there's a lot of
truth um i believe to the whole thing
about the be very careful about what to
say about with the visual effects [ __ ]
of of how a lot of them are feeling like
the it's too much is being stacked up
against them well if you look at the
years it's hard and they demand a lot
from marvel and there's often a lot of
you gotta like oh we need to do this and
they're like down to the release day
visual effects
houses and artists
are often pushed to the limits and for
not enough money yes that's the big
issue and i'm glad that natalie portman
recently gave a lot of credit when's
your talk about that best buy thing yeah
yeah she was like that is uh like it's
such a credit testament to the visual
effects department that they were able
to pull that off i i think
the two years we missed of having movies
and them getting stacked up like i think
it was meant to be two or three a year
and now it's four a year but
plus
shows
i think the feeling of quantity is just
because of like the stagnation but you
got to remember if you're feeling like
it's a lot imagine working on them like
it's insane just in any level like
editor visual effects anything so um the
fact that we're getting them of this
caliber at all is is miraculous i mean i
i think that the lack of quality
sometimes feels like it's really coming
down to run time sometimes i even you
know just an edit sometimes you feel
that would like the disney plus shows of
like goddamn these finales why is it
specifically why is this specifically
two hours like jesus like just a couple
a little bit more time of your show it
feels like when they let them uh like
flow freely with the directing style
then they put other things in a box like
runtime like the shows are really
creative six episodes so it's
interesting what's working and what
isn't imagined they were like we gotta
cut 20 minutes out of no way home yeah
imagine if they said that or like end
games three hours take an hour out yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah all right can we go to the
next uh sp chat here you bet you
hey
you know honestly that dwayne the rock
joke so funny to me didn't catch it
until you guys were pointing out how you
relate to catching it oh yeah we had
like a one beat delay yeah like john and
i were like one way
and i was yeah it was i i did not catch
the joke until you guys were saying that
at the premiere yeah and then i was like
oh such a joke
i love that joke so much yeah
i wonder how dwayne feels about that in
real life arnov probably
probably sai i'm gonna go with that uh
based on thor love and thunder what are
your predictions on the next marvel
movie by the way
move marvel move where is marvel gonna
move their operation to now yes warner
brothers that's the plan
to sony uh i think the next i don't know
i mean koi give a like a 30 second
prediction on what you think they're
going to unveil that we haven't heard of
like comic-con
yeah other than being like guys blade's
coming fantastic four's coming we're
working on mutants uh i think we're
gonna we might get a young avengers
announcement at comic con we're [ __ ]
fighting every everything we ever do now
young avengers how did this movie happen
how did this movie it's like the mcu is
setting it up with like a push-up and
then your cassie links america's
shopping in america
and then from falcon and winter street
there you go i'm not wrong uh i think
either uh d23 or comic-con i would say
d23 i think comic-con is gonna be very
video based i think we're gonna get our
first black panther trailer i think
doctor doom is coming in black panther i
think that's going to set up a very
political side of things which is going
to allow the young avengers to thrive
with all the politics of law
i agree with you i know you've been
posted
but i think that's going to tie into the
legal side with like she-hulk and those
things so i think what we're doing is
we're building out like systems we're
going to be building out a legal system
with she-hulk and matt murdock coming
back in echo i think matt murdock also
shows up in she-hulk i think that's
going to lead to kamala's law with the
end of miss marvel going into young
avengers i think the uh government
entities are going to be emboldened with
thunderbolts when the good guys are
revealed to be bad guys whether they
call it dark avengers or thunderbolts
but i think as far as the cosmic side i
think it's going to come to a really
interesting head in guardians of the
galaxy 3 because we're getting kang in
fantastic uh in ant-man we're getting i
think high evolutionary in guardians of
the galaxy three and then i think when
we do bring in fantastic four they're
gonna have to go a little bit more
contained to the villain so they can
make the cosmic stuff work with what
they've already built so i think
basically we're gonna be dealing with is
ground level government cosmic entity
tiny why me craziness and then the
politics of what it looks like to try to
control a world that deals with all of
that nice
good politics marvel i mean people are
going to love god fights i'm very i'm
very impressed and it's funny like
because i'm so
uh most of them i'm very involved with
with the koi's videos
and and then to
like you say stuff now i'm like i know
what that is now i understand the
aspects of what this one and half the
time i don't retain information so i'm
just like he said come on
yeah when you when you were like editing
the other one you're like i get this now
and you like texted me or like i
understand we were trying to stay and i
was like oh good i'm glad it made sense
and then yeah even like on kamala like
there are some things koi will some
before he films usually i'm like i need
a kind of a recap of what we might talk
what we might talk about so we can kind
of work on structuring this video and
then like i remember you were trying to
explain kamala's law to me i'm like uh
sure like yeah just filmed third in
there at the end uh tired and tied
together and then makes that make sense
once i was working on the video that i
was like oh that is interesting
today that was the first video the one
we dropped today was the first time i
was like i don't know if this makes any
sense like i literally was so worried
that you had to have the inside baseball
knowledge no it's all all tied together
so yeah that was the right thing
all of us worked on that john you me and
all of us did you like it i loved it i
mean i i
it takes me longer than it takes greg
but i really love compiling and doing
the uh touch-ups for koi corners like
they're they're it's really fun to find
all the images and then it's like oh
you're i'm learning along you know i'm
trying to give like 70 years of comics
in like a 20 minute video but you guys
are like let's make it 12.
[Laughter]
seo seo everybody run time uh chris
alire is finally someone asked about
hind uh about axel so i know sarah
williamson in the chat was bringing and
bringing him up axel heinzelson so
heimdall's son can see through people's
eyes but can't summon the bifrost like
his father did he's a kid give him a
break
get there but he could do it with
stormbreaker he could wield it he did
yeah so i think
them out of there i think they are
building to it how do you guys like live
streaming with these i prefer it this is
great
because it's like as much as it is fun
to have like a mic on an arm and feel
like you're in a podcast studio for
everything we do this is just the
easiest i feel more loose yeah but the
uh but i i like to i i really like the
inclusion of axel a lot uh
i mean the the axel joke back and forth
was like
okay
but
but the this what is the thing axel says
to thor when he gets like so fed up with
him when he first shows up in the cage
he's like go away he's like
i love that you're not healthy i thought
that was so funny uh their back and
forth is great i want a deadpool and
thor movie and i'm prepared to forgive
any stillness they come up for fourth
that would make a great comedic duo i
would love ryan reynolds and chris
hemsworth so much can you imagine they
do a deadpool movie and people are like
too many jokes
too much
it was immature
uh but yeah i really liked axel
heimdelson uh i did not expect to be
like so endeared him so quickly but he
was like a good leader role jennifer abe
bourbon uh expresses worry after
watching love and thunder for tyka's
star wars film so i'd put it to the chat
do you guys feel the same i'm not
because
because he did the last episode of the
mandalorian that killed
true that and he did i mean he had like
a funny bit with the stormtroopers but
it was like taking the piss out of
stormtroopers who we already the star
wars fan base clowns storm troopers they
suck
and so um that was like the only bit
that felt like taika directed this
episode yeah i think he's a great
director i think and i i generally like
him better in his own wheelhouse than
like playing with ip like i think jojo
rabbit hunt for the wilderpeople and boy
are all my favorite taika but i am
curious what he does with an entirely
new mega ip like star wars like i can't
even imagine what that is so i'm i'm
curious
yeah i mean i i think thor love and
thunder is the kind of movie that
will grow in appreciation over time
and
anytime there's a movie that has like
negative attention eventually the
offense rises amazing
uh spider-man
yeah i mean this was one where i was
like i felt for the characters more than
a lot of these movies like the
interpersonal journeys and stuff like
that like the things it was truly about
and truly seemed to care about i was
like this is really touching and
wonderful and he does and he does
ultimately still pull from uh
you know lore and and comics i mean he
still does like do it he just
kind of makes fun of it
yeah it just makes it kind of funny ian
schmidt also clarifies heimdall had a
sword and a gold sphere that shot the
biofrost so instruments part of the deal
the sword was how he summoned it attarca
one i just wish the movie was a little
bit more serious it was just too much
joking around
also random question will y'all watch
the terminal list is that the one with
christopher pratt
no he doesn't like the name christopher
he's pratt
prep and apparently
apparently weird update uh he's not
religious
despite posting tons of like i'm getting
my good lord in today okay i don't
usually talk about people's personal
business i like chris pratt the human i
like chris pratt the man but i don't
think this aggressive weird like
pr push is fair to
it just feels like lying like i i i see
what he's trying to do and i'm really
happy for him but like he's putting out
articles that are like we see your
instagram and like i think you just like
if you want to stand for something stand
for it and like i i
don't like a lot of what those things
cause people harm through but i think
like chris is the only dude i worked on
a set with chris and he's the only dude
that knew everything
yeah yeah i played his little brother in
a movie called bride wars and he's the
only dude that knew um
he knew every crew member's name no but
like he knew every crew member's name
like he knew he knew everyone on set and
he was really kind and compassionate i
don't know him now but i do think that
like it's really tricky when you do a pr
campaign that's just like receipts so
it's just it's a mess and uh his name's
pratt i mean when uh
i've read one of the interviews and he
said that he never
that church that uh elliot page said he
was a part of yeah he's never been a
part of that church i hope so and um
but granted that the church he is a part
of has had its controversy
yeah i mean it's a church
um and and and you know he does say like
i because i i have friends who are like
part of the church of jesus like the
part of church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints i have friends who are
christian i have friends who are
catholic i have i have a whole bunch of
friends i have friends
um
but and all and all kinds of faith right
and
and but there is that degree and there's
someone who grew up in catholic school
who who did identify as catholic for a
large part of my life
there are those degrees of like yeah i i
do consider my you're [ __ ] irish you
know like you know that there's like
there's the there's the the real
catholic people who are like
religious [ __ ] and then there's people
who are just like yeah i i am but you
know i still like
drink and [ __ ] right
now i'm not there every sunday my life
yeah so um there's uh and and chris
pratt strikes me out to be a little bit
more that version a lot at least in the
way he talks in interviews he's like if
he was really that super religious i
imagine he'd be doing he doesn't
some of the movies he does and some of
the jokes
and wreck the jokes he makes on par what
do you see in bloopers and the way he
talks in interviews and the stories he
tells and stuff yeah i just you know
it's a tricky thing to do to defend her
or to admonish anyone i think he's more
religious than he lets on but i don't
think he's as religious
i think he's somewhere in the middle
where it's like yeah this this but it's
just the pr around it is very strange it
is a weird i don't know i don't know it
doesn't really matter to me
he's not harming people as long as he's
not hurting anyone and i'm only in one
scene in bride words there i was in
three but the movie became uh a
different thing in the ending room but
i'm in one scene it's actually really
funny because anne hathaway and chris
pratt are getting married and i'm in a
bunch of scenes setting up that scene
but by the time the final cut comes out
it's like they're zooming in on chris
pratt and then they zoom in right on my
face and it cuts away but they're like
who's who's that guy and it's like my
favorite thing about real because it's
like and koi's here
and it just leaves i literally tried to
pull up a picture of you in that movie
yeah there's like i'm just it's
bride wars chris pratt's in that yeah
he's the uh the one anne hathaway mary's
but i'm literally only in the marriage
scene now like i'm only in the wedding
scene uh but yeah just briefly just a
real quick thing dude
we need to take a take on quiet place
three so we can have yo yo
let's do it was not religious during
parks and ranch yes
i don't keep track of all that personal
life stuff personally i just hope he's
happy and hope he's not hurting people
we should go over chris pratt's imdb and
then chart his religiosity tony stark go
to valhalla we need an after live show
we need to just know what's going on
just to know where all of our where are
our marvel characters i know also mike
kalinowski's on terminalist is there oh
hey good for him friend of the front of
the real answers from him is there a
weigh station where like every dead soul
goes to and they're like what are you
you're norris okay you're going to
valhalla someone's like sorting the
luggage you're greek yeah yeah you're
going here uh egyptian-ish okay
and these afterlifes feel like physical
planes so i'm like did half the spirits
in valhalla disappear like what are the
rules uh
wesley kevin
wesley phelps i liked the movie but
there is one thing that i was confused
about how did jane get from her hospital
bed to the center of the universe with
just
mjolnir know
uh i just kind of chalked that up to
with mjolnir you can fly and it doesn't
seem to be a hindrance that they're out
in space where no air exists but they
needed
they needed stormbreaker and the ship
maybe because there was multiple of them
maybe it took because she's just her
maybe she was just like i'm gonna
helicopter my way there i don't know
it's a good question you know i hadn't
thought of that it's just herself and
not the creature i forgave a lot in the
dark knight rises
[Laughter]
how did he make that big gasoline bat
signal why was that worth the time he's
thinking of gotham
how did he just get back to god and it's
funny i didn't really register that she
flies in on valkyrie's steed
uh at the end there too she takes
mjolnir but she also has the horse yeah
ian schmidt points out
whose name i'm forgetting because it's
not pegasus is it it is a pegasus right
yeah
well anyhow all right it's a talking
horse in the comics and he's great
he's got a shot soul of frigga in there
yep hanging out
chillin
speaking of entertaining flev doran
i've been watching you guys for a long
time and i haven't seen such a perfect
chemistry from a third person like coy
has with you guys great i just hope
everyone we've ever brought on here
hears that watching right now
aaron
alexander andrew gordon yeah
all of us females everyone the monolith
of female guests
i mean there's i mean there's a
freaking um what's his name oh my god
ace i've gotten to know through him
being here like i was getting to know
koya for quite a while like we were both
getting friends
before yeah you came on and but ace i
was like i don't know ace that well
because
for sure we'll hang out for six hours
off topic though koi oh what shows other
than the mcu ones are you currently
watching tell them about the show you
were raving about when you walked in
here man wu tang and american saga ain't
nothing to [ __ ] wit uh wu-tang american
saga is like if the crime thriller
elements of breaking bad had a sweet
sweet baby with walk the line it is one
of the best biopics i've ever seen is
one of the best crime thrillers i've
ever seen and it's about 90 statin
island it's about xiao lin it's about
the birth of what modern hip-hop is in
my opinion it's about the greatest rap
group of all time and it's masterfully
directed with some of the most creative
shots about the birth of creativity i've
ever seen the acting is top notch if you
care about method man rizza odb
geezy any of the wu-tang clan
you get to experience how they came to
be you get to experience some of their
own history they balance a lot of tones
really well they do the thing that
daredevil does well where opposing
viewpoints are each given their time to
shine so you're conflicted as a viewer
as to what you want to expect i cannot
sing the praises higher of wu-tang
american saga it's on hulu it's got a
lot of emmys it's going into its third
and final season this year so you got
only two seasons 20 hours of peak
television to enjoy um and also ted
lasso changed my life uh it was great i
think those are my top two right now but
i went on a long rant about uh mine is
uh love is blind
uh
on the boys
i mean no i'm not no no i don't want
mention shows everybody watch here love
is
blind great reality show
and uh better call saul i'm excited for
that yet
god i love better yeah that's great
stranger things i'm never gonna react to
it here don't ever ask me and uh
afterlife
ricky gervais we got a lot of shows
atlanta
oh i'm so i gotta see season three
atlanta atlanta's love on the spectrum
amazing show
pam and tommy was pretty good rick and
morty season five finally started oh
yeah though i mean wu-tang ted lasso are
my big ones uh stranger things is right
there up with it uh cobra kai is awesome
um yeah i think those are mine those are
my go-to's i've seen no new tv that you
haven't witnessed me watching here this
is just us
this is us get your therapy on you
lovelies
pegasus was perseus
purse
go down a little bit
aragorn nah that's not true is it no it
can't be that would be too much
are you done reading super chats
no no we got more in fact i am worried
about daredevil disney plus i've been
worried about we did a whole video about
it
i've been worried about daredevil disney
plus for a while
method man wasn't looking very long very
long time man all righty
cinema reviews like are there people who
get upset when like we have the
regular chat here we interact with we
try but you know someone contributes
super chess people get upset but also
i'm just like oh [ __ ] okay sorry we're
doing both you're upset
what do we do here i'm just we're trying
it's a lot going on thanks to everybody
chiming in the bridge we appreciate the
super jazz ragnarok is still everyone's
best favorite of all the thors uh this
is pretty much how you expect it elise
is number two yeah eleven thunder strong
number two thor the original number
three and everybody doesn't love the
dark i weirdly thought that it might be
a little bit closer with the first thor
movie i like thor more than most the
first thor i think i hold closer it's a
bit of an underappreciated gym i do too
and i just rewatched it on thursday on
thor's day we did all four of the movies
we got the shirt yeah and like
re-watching it holds up real well i i
think it's
i think and and chris
hemsworth's funny in it too yeah and
like the world they built incredible i
love the texture of the the wardrobe's
great i love the texture of the world i
love asgard i think loki's phenomenal in
it he's a bit more like animalistic
yeah yeah i mean they've definitely like
funnied up everyone
david valenzuela in the chats is what we
do in the shadows terrific i'm not
caught up but the probably the most
recent outside show i have
seen uh would have been our flag means
death which is uh taika and company so
christina thank you white bear is
awesome good to know heard the bear is
awesome i haven't had time to watch it
yet but i've worked in restaurants so
i'm curious i don't know if it's going
to give me trauma though working in
restaurants cinema reviews how uh with
how he diagnosed thor in ragnarok and
valkyrie in this korg should really
consider becoming a therapist for mcu
heroes i would love taika just
therapizing like winter soldier he's
just got the white wolf in his chair
he's he was explaining um who how he
views korg
and it suddenly
completely clicked with me when he
explained it of how
he views korg as a new zealand bouncer
oh a hundred percent yeah
like they're they're like these big guys
who can [ __ ] you up but but they're just
sweethearts they're so nice and so soft
spoken yeah yeah
and i was like oh yeah yeah that's a
good thing that is that is core yeah i
love that so much but i forgot that
what's the race cronin crown ronan
uh dark world at the very beginning
i forgot about it if you'd known you
could have one of uh a mjolnir ice tray
i still have the morbius poster i won
from you in the back of my car
that makes me so happy it's always in
the back of my car
buried in my trunk i like to give out
things it lives in my trunk that's
michael richie fpl swanson hello to
scotland and hey glad you were at the
cinema good uh patronage b-funk 3778
john what is this this is a moment of
silence and we are very grateful
we like moments of silence
don't go all chris pratt on us i'm so
sorry
i don't really talk singing over here
i've never seen the boondocks what
that's a reaction waiting to happen
no there's two i know i saw the second
one actually i saw kill bill two before
i saw kill bill what
yeah did you should really see the
second one
i have some duck saints for kill bill no
i haven't seen any of them i'm so
excited for you to see william defoe and
buddhadox saints i am about to have a
religious experience with william to
phone boondocks that's the number one
thing i'm excited about that's
incredible yeah you've seen boondock
saints i saw it twice when i was really
really young he is just such a vibe in
that movie i honestly can't tell you
what the hell the plot is
i've seen it i just remember
all i remember are moments of willem
dafoe when he's in bed with the one guy
and then uh and then when he's doing
like the gun two dudes are hunting down
bad guys like like the punisher and like
they're oh i thought they're bad guy
that's how little i remember you'll see
oh wait it wouldn't remember it's coming
some of it's coming back to me a little
bit it's all in boston the conflict that
happens or willem dafoe yeah
it's a good time
it's shockingly like [ __ ] gay no no
it's just shockingly it's not a
homosexual he just is gay which is like
way ahead of its time like he just
happens to be gay hey amanda hernandez
hasn't seen it either so i'm not alone
he just happens to be that's good that's
how characters should be yeah don't make
a big deal out of it harry says
i'm starting to get concerned as a long
time mcu fan since 2000
ever since the incredible hope iron man
i've been really worried yeah incredible
i think she's saying she or he is is a
fan since 2008 but i like the idea of
the being concerned since i am starting
to get concerned over 10 years
of frustration
i don't know how this is going to go
really quick in the chat man delorean
wants to know do you think there's a
chance for bald or the brave or angela
to appear in future thorough movies
apparently bald of the brave has been
cast and has been meant to appear in all
four uh thor movements i don't know who
it is i don't know what that is but it's
so funny to me i doubt it but maybe and
i don't know how they're gonna use
angela and i don't know about the legal
rights to angela because angela was
actually an image comics creation that
they retconned into being thor's sister
so angela was invented in the todd
mcfarlane image comics era and in a full
run over there she has been acquired by
marvel comics and is now canon as thor's
sister but i don't know about the legal
rights to put those characters on film
also tripe x says thor ragnarok had the
best thor best loki best odin best
villain best humor best hulk grand
masters there best action scenes and
best fight scene
yeah i think thor ragnarok's just is a
cooler movie it's pretty cool i think
it's like a cooler it's p sick yeah
although what i will say for the like i
and i i love that it's like part of me
goes it also has loki
but then i was like
i didn't miss loki here
i don't think this story needed loki no
no i'm glad they didn't try to shoot
ornament because of his popularity yeah
uh and also uh korg therapy webisodes
all day that would be a good marvel
marvel quibby show uh korg therapy
underrated michael mack says scene was
korg and val uh heart to heart at the
bar and karaoke disney plus should bring
back one shots what would you want to
see korg therapy one shots we just wrote
it i want a lot of well i would think
they should do more one shot i think
that was a really cool like not only can
they like flesh out mythology and help
you fix things like the mandarin
but i don't know i feel like those are
great opportunities for filmmakers to
cut their teeth and to do something
interesting in the world without having
to be so kind of
in the nexus of a bunch of moving parts
you know i'd like to see some spider-man
stuff like just outside of canon like a
fight or a high school class or any of
like the him just getting to be peter
parker we haven't gotten a lot of that
and now that he's kind of on his own i'd
love to see some peter parker's stuff
like rebuilding pedro parkour i want to
see
what the kids in the cage talked about
in this movie yeah team kids in the cage
team kids in a cave there's also what
was is there any significance or is it
just a game of thrones reference that
the uh
uh
uh [ __ ] i'm forgetting their name now
the god of uh korg's people
is on an iron throne made of scissors
instead of swords oh
i didn't even catch that and i've seen
it three times that's amazing i wasn't
even 100 sure it was a game of thrones
reference or not it just looks so like
does it just look like the iron throne
yeah i'm like what's the significance of
all the scissors
is it just and it's rock paper scissors
right that's the joke i think it is the
joke either well done
boys
comedy corner i didn't even see the
thing you're talking about i'm like
rocks scissors toys comedy corner then
and yeah that's my favorite humor kieran
the scene thank you for uh the concord
paper for jumping in kieran it's so good
the scene
if that's the joke it's conquered
scissors
because paper and paper is taken out
yeah so rock overseas i'm still on this
joke
oh beautiful it's the gift that keeps
giving kirid the scene of thor and jane
in the hospital had me in tears likewise
the way chris delivered the line because
i love you was the most human line i've
heard in a film ever that and and that
and the great scene yeah and the weight
and the way he throws away that line of
like well that was before i knew you
might not actually have time left you
know yeah it was one of those things
that flew so beautifully after that
moment of like wow we don't know how
much time we have like that's such a
human moment to be like well that was
before i knew
you know
something that really
has to be credited despite what you even
think about the first half of this movie
upsetting you with the amount of comedy
or whatever
is
if it wasn't for taika waititi directing
this film we would not have had such a
vastly imp improved chemistry with with
natalie christian
because
and i think that gets overlooked just
how much if you watch thor or the dark
world and then you watch this
it's like oh wow their chemistry is so
as if it's always been great yeah
but in that retroactive scene where they
build in the story that we'd never got
like they're like let's see them dating
that montage they have more chemistry
there than all of them
everything we've seen yeah and in 10
minutes they fixed two movies yeah and
then and that first time we saw it i was
getting cynical at the start of the
montage of like oh okay here's the
retcon and then buy the you know a
couple frames and i'm like oh but this
is so lovely as soon as she's got her
chest bursting out in the bed and he's a
hot dog oh i like the little ranch
that's love and like the little random
visuals like when they are separated on
the couch and when they're showing their
distance and he's got it's like you
might miss it but he's got like the
hammer placed in between yeah yeah
instead of like a pillow
and i think too it's like it it smoothed
out the character of jane well because
in the first movie i liked her she's
fine in the second movie i was like
she's gotten like wacky in a weird way i
don't understand
and then in this movie i thought that
they balanced the two out they
synthesized those two flavors and she
became an actual character they did with
uh her here what they did with him and
infinity ward in game like they found
they found jane foster here yeah i think
she's i think their chemistry is like i
it was so it's it's so natural here that
you forget that it it wasn't this good
before right yeah like you and it would
not have worked as a film if they didn't
fix it and then you needed taika
waititi's style and direction to truly
capture that because we've had two
directors try already yep and it did not
do it you had the great oscar-winning
kenneth brauna direct them in the first
one and it did not do it you know they
had to give her a ramp to kiss him oh
really literally not even uh not even
the boxes they usually use they had to
build a ramp because he is like that
much taller than her she had to walk up
to him wowie
oh goodness i had a question and i've
forgotten it so let's move ahead
all right
uh what season are you on for agents of
shield logan
oh yes uh the series finale will be up
this weekend i am i am
so it's a whole lot of stuff that is
season seven seasons
that's a lot of shield that is a lot of
shield i was so cynical
really i don't know who wrote it to
really
is it i've never seen the show
i love like i i started so cynically and
it was at a time where i was like i
already watched all these marvel movies
do i really want to commit to 20
episodes of network marvel uh but it it
like i cannot sing the praises uh i know
i see you
skeptical i'm happy you're happy uh but
i i've read
i have really enjoyed it comic book or
whatever aside i i think they they
really managed to create some fun and
interesting writing on that it's got a
strong fan base and a great ensemble and
yeah they're like i would be so excited
to see quake come to the mcu or
something like that or or any of uh
the ensembl
uh but yeah i think mel gibson should be
the next door that's
yes agreed
into the galaxy what are the
conversations on that side he's peter
quill's uncle
whoo i was gonna say has any mcu
property gotten as much retroactive
bolstering as
thor specifically the dark world but
thor generally because not even like age
of ultron or or certain of the other
lesser-loved no they really put in the
work to fix like for whatever reason
it's that franchise keeps getting these
retroactive improvements because like
iron man's just i mean iron man had the
one shot that worked in the mandarin but
like iron man's two is is just like
passable like it's not i don't know if
they've used any of that lore whereas
you need the thor lore so i don't know
and then cap like the the three caps are
pretty consistent
true hell yeah
apparently natalie portman was on the
wrap for all the walking scenes as well
she's very small kiells or keiz samau
i'm sure i butchered your name there
could you guys do the gore dance what's
the gorgeous gore dance he has talked
about this christian bale they had a
kate bush uh dance sequence that they
worked on
and it never was filmed because they
were like they're never gonna let us
shoot this but he worked out some kind
of dance
to kate bush kate bush was almost in the
two biggest things of the summer and i
don't know if it was running up that
hill or a different joint from kate bush
but uh i i'm just so thrilled for
i wish i hope it is right that it just
sort of ruins everything from stranger
things
he even cited like her as an inspiration
for how he shaped gore's character like
he was like really he listed like three
things like apex
twins
uh kate bush and then like what are this
ferrara yeah yeah that those are his
inspirations for gore i would love to
see that dance i i hope that he'll do it
like as a viral video or some silly
little online thing or something it is
apex right affects
there's a ph yeah it is a fixed twin
yeah got it apologies all right i've
been fans i've made that uh error to
become an apex predator hey
remember when that was the it word of
every blockbuster for two years every
movie and it was like the year after
club reveal because they clearly wrote
it after watching glow reveals those
little gap and then like apex predator
oh yeah julia zona is gonna do uh uh the
new captain america cloverfield paradox
director oh yeah that's funny i also
directed loose which is good you know
what's funny about the captain america
movie is that
anthony mackie will return
as sam
wilson not as but not as falcon yeah
what a crazy did you see this article
the variety reported on it
i've had some sassy interactions last
couple days with some great reporting
how they reported it
he's going to return but not his falcons
you wanna hear the real that's what they
said
good i mean just for clarification chris
evans had to come out on twitter and say
that he is captain guys i'm white so let
me let you know check this out anthony
mackie is reprising his longtime marvel
character of sam wilson but will not
however portray wilson's longtime alter
ego and captain america sidekick falcon
that's how they announced
the positioning of anthony matthews say
i tweeted breaking captain america two
star in captain america four
and then chris evans recently reached
out and said sam wilson is captain
america under that tweet like chris
evans is like
so um yeah sam and david mccasey sam
wilson's captain america still isn't in
the marvel studios logo
it's interesting like
unless that's
a very very
uh sort of oddly timed attempted not
spoiling falcon in the winter soldier
that's a very silly tweet
a very silly way to put that i'm very uh
yeah yeah no no logan he corrected me
instantaneously yeah it was hollywood
reporter not variety
yeah
how fast did you type that
you know in what milliseconds
we got a bunch of people saying
wuthering heights is the kate bush song
they could see gore dancing to so uh
have to go give that one a list i think
it should be like uh chris uh jim
carrey's dance number and tonic the
hedgehog movie yes jay tavo for me the
emotion of jane's death and thor's
declaration of love was undercut by the
trivialization of many of the other
stakes throughout the film
i suppose
i do think that
it would sometimes forget to check in on
the the jane storyline of her with the
cancer mm-hmm like it would it i would i
would forget about it
until
until like oh yeah yeah that's a thing
that happened i think the second half
just really kind of
i just i wanted something sprinkling
into that first half man i think there
needed i think it needed another 20
minutes yeah and like 12 or 14 of them
in the first half and then like six more
yeah like it's mainly front loading that
first half yeah
but i agree
and hey apparently miss marvel made it
into it we gotta get
coy out of here
really he's got sharp he's a two-hour
man he's sharp two hours see if there's
any that have my name in him before i
leave because it's it's two hours now
but let's see if we got anything this is
one started at 12 10. i know it's 1204.
it's 204. i got six minutes i was trying
to get six minutes coy i was trying to
be official five and a half
yeah pond i loved this movie from thor's
split we're just talking to john's like
beef exclusive i have a question for a
boy
this super challenge literally has your
name in this
i loved this movie from thor's split to
the little girl going ham with her
stuffed bunny just seeing eternity on
screen for coy
isn't dane whitman's sword also a necro
sword same power set okay so the necro
sword is a a type of power and it is
very similar in that dane whitman's
sword corrupts uh his sword is a little
less um
uh toxic
physically but mentally it's more toxic
so like it's it leads him even when not
willing it to be instinctively drawn to
do things that are bad so what's cool
about the character we're gonna get with
dan whitman is that basically he's a
good guy but he keeps being told by the
thing that gives him power to [ __ ] up so
uh it's gonna be really interesting to
see how a hero takes on the necrosword
type energy so yes you're totally right
that is what's to come and i do think
this was a great way to introduce that
concept uh i don't know if we're gonna
get the same like tenderly visuals but
there is a symbiote like energy to both
swords
mike k i'm doing all the kois uh
watching we're gonna we're not skipping
anyone's progress
that way we get the ones specifically
aimed for koi i have the last one we did
highlighted so i won't be highlighting
these ones right now just so we can save
our place but watching koi's post
credits break down then seeing the movie
again got me really excited for what we
could be seeing in the future is
literally the best compliment i can
receive uh people buying comics because
i recommended them more people saying
they enjoyed something more is literally
all i want to do with my knowledge is
like i'm not a critic i don't like to
tear things down i like to build things
up so if you were able to enjoy
something because of of different
perspective i gave you then i have done
my job and i'm that means the world
thank you for telling me you gotta tear
something down once in a while the
irishman oh my god
[Laughter]
all this time we've never even dived
into the specifics of why i don't like
it it's just some running commentaries
what the [ __ ]
you going [ __ ] sucks
a really fun show if you do like a watch
along commentary with one person who
loves the pro and one person who is anti
and crossfire yeah exactly but over a
movie you're ruining my enjoyment
experience
it would be really fun to be like why do
you like this scene why don't you like
this yeah like beat by beat
let's suffer through the irishman
together greg r is probably you have to
pause the movie to do that and then
very tricky
aries says uh 72 hour stream please i
agree tim infinity
off topic question for koi do you think
the mcu will ignore or reclassify new
humans and introduce inhumans solely as
the royal cosmicky ones so i do feel
like new humans um will kind of be
folded into inhumans at least in the
beginning they might get another tier
where like inhumans have already been
established enough that new humans can
be a thing but i think in the beginning
we are gonna see inhumans and i do think
uh the royalty element will be a factor
i do think there's gonna be like a bit
of a hierarchy um i i personally am of
the mind that the terrigen missed was
what we experienced to miss marvel i do
think that was something akin to a
target missed it really looks like it
looks so much like it so whether or not
we address it now the cool thing about
these shows is the next episode doesn't
have to spell it out we could then have
in captain marvel 2 the marvels they
could
do that storyline on the big screen
because you honestly might want to
explain the terrigen mist to the theater
audience because some people don't watch
the show so you might want to save the
inhumans development there so by
planting these seeds on miss marvel i do
think we're leading towards inhumans and
i do think that's also going to give us
an interesting conflict with x-men which
are only a few years away
that's a great way
to say bye to you is that it hey guys
will bachelor
so this is the great way to say
sending love from north carolina happy
to see koi's edition i was introduced to
him from collider heroes and was sad
when that ended me too man also i was
born in greensboro uh near greensboro
virginia i mean no greensboro north
carolina danville virginia is where i
was born near you okay sorry
all right that is uh oh is that it
believe that it's the last koi thank you
so much i'm so glad to be closed the
supers if that's the move
and wait off
we're going to be here for a while okay
much love reject nation you guys are
amazing
corey say it better goodbye
reject nation i appreciate you all so
much uh thank you for all the love
you've given koi's comic corner thank
you for all the love you've sent me on
twitter and instagram please do follow
me on tik tok i am gonna be trying to do
more short concise um
15 one minute videos uh 15 second videos
explaining some of the stuff i do right
here but the welcome has been absolutely
incredible i think if it wasn't called
the irishman i'd enjoy it more because
i mean we'll get we'll talk about it uh
but i do appreciate all the love and uh
you guys are the best and i love doing
the show here and i will be back on
tuesday for miss marvel with these gents
and we are cooking something up oh we
mentioned at the top uh we're gonna do a
full on mcu ranking all of the movies i
might sprinkle in the shows we'll see if
i got time but the entire mcu to date
ranked and that's gonna be really fun
and it's just my opinion it's only my
take so don't take it personally just
know it's my personal journey with it so
much love i'll see you guys soon
all right i'm just gonna walk coy out
john you better hold down this live
stream you're gonna go from
two three energies of three people to
just want me
and john you're gonna have to make a
video
so i hope you just yell
and yell because i hope your mind goes
that's the equivalent of three people
right me screaming at everyone
i'll see you down there i'll see you san
diego okay bye oh yeah go go touch koi
go touch koi and and uh breathe on his
face
yes it's every implication you need
ryan wright versus thor is what i want
to see definitely and uh there's i i
love that koi is inspired so much
i uh irishman love in here yes olenti
coy is our comic book guru and lots of
love for the god of dumplings in here
which i i do appreciate i feel like as
much as people have begrudged the comedy
of this film everybody does appreciate
bow which i also appreciate
um
but yes uh ant-man has trouble calling
captain calling sam captain slash falcon
and sam correctly said he's cap on the
cruise ship adventure is that like wait
a minute is that like a real cruise ship
thing
captain zilenski is truly captain
ukraine dang i'm surprised i bet there
are a lot of artist renderings of that
out there
um
captain japanese jesus
there should be a captain for every
single country and then just personify
the weirdness of uh the world at large
uh
yeah guys
what was your favorite moment overall
from the film favorite comedic moment
uh uh favorite anything moment but
especially because the comedy has been
so
debated and and such a point of
contention was there any particular joke
even if you weren't a fan of the first
half of the movie or the overall
reliance on humor was there anything
that you guys thought was particularly
inspired particularly funny
uh i would love to know
that uh hey thanks i did my best after
doctor strange too i i you know
it's a you the group dynamic brings a
lot and i do my level best in these
moments not to bore you guys because you
know status three becoming status one is
always an interesting adventure and
sometimes you find out watching a movie
like in the hangover three that a side
character is probably best used as a
side character rather than as the focus
so i appreciate uh that anyhow welcome
back decoy oh my god i'm in the chat
[ __ ] photo
oh that's not actually you no it's not
me how would it be
i don't know i mean you could have your
own this is the only youtube channel can
you uh please pull up our frame so i
could so we could readjust it yeah i i
i
thought that you might have your own
gmail for just greg alba and you know if
you have a gmail you have a youtube
account someone wants to hack my
personality use it act like it's me yeah
say terrible things to terrible people
hit up people for favors can't see if
you can strike up collabs you used to
use my name
jared zeus walking down the stairs i
asked everybody because the comedy has
been so contentious of this movie uh
what's everyone's favorite bit of comedy
you know a bit of uh joke making
handshake with star-lord handshake with
star-lord stormbreaker and thor is a
popular one that whole relationship how
funny would it have been if i stepped
out just so i could log into my personal
youtube account just to get into the
live stream that's what i thought was
happening
it's like hey sounds like something
funny it sounds like something like that
yeah
by the way for everyone here forgot to
mention um sally lamonico who uh used to
come on his channel all the time before
she moved away uh she's gonna be she
hasn't seen most of the mcu movies and
she's only and the one she has seen
she's only seen once forever ago
so much so
that um uh we did she did so what was
like wow you really haven't seen these
movies
we uh she's doing marvel movie reactions
for us and she just started we're gonna
put up iron man of hers tomorrow
and i had to like do an insert in the
video saying right now i was like yeah
so sally didn't watch the post-credits
scene because she completely forgot that
there are post-credits scenes in these
movies that should be an instagram web
series of sally's quick post-credit
reactions like this is the proof in the
puddings right here that she does not
know these movies the fact that she did
not stay for a post credit scene i was
like wait you know there's a post credit
scenes you got to stick around for right
she's like no oh my god
uh this is an mc noob but it's fun
watching her reactions to [ __ ] so you
shouldn't seen like the avengers movies
and all that so i'm gonna i think uh
it's gonna be something awesome
it's gonna be exciting i'm excited i'm
excited for the new joker movie i hope
they kind of do my cult of joker film
it's gonna happen
they've been watching these videos
wait what wasn't you someone in the chat
is uh has a greg alba icon here yeah
someone's stolen greg's identity and is
using it for hijinks uh what do you need
advice on sarah williamson we can try
and yes greg will be marrying sally uh
polygamy is legal
david lyman lemon la mean
third fave in phase four after shang chi
in no way home bale and portman were
standouts kid fight was hype shocked win
fight get fight good fight yeah good
fight team kids in a fight get the kids
fighting throw some money down for them
kid fights
battle it out kids kid i got blu-ray dvd
what do you want kid fight song is there
actual parts in the world where they do
that
oh my god now it's not funny anymore
shocked when initially thought korg died
they're a real kid no they don't know
like they were dying i thought they
might have milked that a tad bit more
because i was shocked too i was like oh
my god i killed off cork yeah it was too
and then immediately he's fine
i love how matter of fact the super chat
is comedy's fine and overhated hemsworth
will forever be thor get over it guys
i mean kinda well i mean he will he is
he is indelibly it's it's like for as
much as people
are torn about the comedy and as much as
that might come from him i feel like
there is something it's like that
i was realizing yesterday
and i'm sure i've thought about it
before but it's just like wow
the way they cast at least this first
the first wave has been fascinating and
they did make some like iconic it seems
like choices in people like chris
hemsworth or downey jr or chris evans or
you know i mean it seems like he in the
movie though because everyone a lot of
people seem to harp on the fact that
he's like a more buffoonish than before
yeah
and it seems like throughout the movie
as he gets more in tune with the truth
within himself he the buffoonish quality
starts to diminish
yeah
so i feel like it kind of
it's intentional i see the the complaint
that it's maybe inconsistent with
previous characterizations but to me
it's what you said all of thor's yeah
and and it to me it's what you said and
also that for the first part of the
movie i think part of the point is that
he's teetering on being part of the
problem gore is describing in the first
place he's they call him god of
destruction once he actually you know
saves the people of that planet and
utterly destroys their sacred shrine
you know he's he's easily teetering on
being you know that negligent you know
destructive force or or you know
so i feel like there's a lot in the
themes of the movie that motivate that
too
poven-meyer yep when thor a score at the
end what he was seeking i thought
the means to fight injustice
hmm
that's a good what's that a reference to
i mean i hear injustice and i just think
of dc villains
but uh
i don't know i mean i think that's kind
of at the core of what gore is getting
to is sort of like a reckoning for the
true you know cosmic imbalance of you
know uh
we're led to believe that these gods are
are looking out for our best interests
and you know and have you know
some kind of provision and concern for
their people
uh but it turns out not and that is a
great injustice
um
you know i mean he comes to this god
prostrate after you know the wiping out
of his entire people which you would
argue is an injustice is jojo rabbit
r-rated yes i believe it is god i would
love to see an r-rated version of this
yeah right
i feel like
this is one of those further we get
both doctors both multiverse and madness
and this movie i'm like those would be
good r-rated films yeah they would yeah
absolutely i don't really get that
feeling too often with the mcu films
but this
these last two movies i i did find
myself going these would be good r-rated
films yeah
then we would get our god butchering
yeah yeah
i mean that is kind of the the the part
i think of why i i think it's totally
okay to expect more god butcher because
even even the in the beginning
when thor stabs that one god in the
throat it's pretty violent to look at it
at first especially in your first few
minutes when everyone here as i can
imagine you're hearing like a movie's
just a wacky comedy and then that first
ten minutes is like super dark and then
in the beginning he stabs that that
gonna reveals like oh there's a knife a
sword just in a person's throat yeah
it's kind of
jarring at first yeah and uh and and
after seeing doctor strange which
pushed the violence boundary quite a bit
uh you would think they would be like a
little bit okay with i don't know i
guess tonally too like this movie's also
definitely appealing to families way
more than
doctor strange is attempting to you know
yeah i mean i feel like dr strange is
trying to get to the r whereas this one
is sort of it winds up there naturally
but not on purpose if that makes sense
jared dyer thank you hey guys didn't
love this one as much as ragnarok but
still really enjoyed what do you guys
think he who remains
uh wish to eternity was
is there a thing established in there
that he who remains made a wish to
eternity
i mean it wouldn't make sense with what
the movie lays out because isn't it that
the first person to reach eternity gets
the wish and gore ostensibly would be
the first person to reach attorneys oh
is the rule the first person i don't
know how strict it is but i believe
that's what they say
is like he's looking for eternity
and the first person i i think that's
how it was phrased is the first person
to reach it gets the twist or gets the
wish can you guys clarify in the chat
for us if uh there's a whole thing here
about um
i mean i didn't catch anything about he
remains unless unless it's about um
i mean unless his visit shows up in that
temple somewhere
family's coming out to see thor's ass
that's right
a lot of people are
and the mcu they say first person in
thor 11 thunder yeah
okay okay so i don't know
i mean i guess he who remains would wish
for the wish
i want my wish
damn gore it's pretty impressive yeah
and that image of him just crawling
through the hole is uh is lovely okay
everyone's uh correcting me for sure
yeah i was 100 wrong on that
uh i don't know i don't know what he who
remains wish would be
so are you getting sick of all these
marvel movies
no not really
it's it's a
it's a i don't know like i i yeah i
wondered at one point if i would but
they're always fun it's always a fun
prompt you know
i think weirdly because they're not
reliant on setting up other movies like
it's not as just set up other movies or
being insanely connected to other films
that
it's not wearing on me and this it
doesn't wear on me in the same way
if that makes sense because i think the
problem before when people were always
like a little bit concerned about too
much marvel movies
the feeling was it kind of felt like you
were watching like
sequels to a certain extent like
obviously not
but in a way they all kind of are
sequels to each other and this is the
time when they haven't been feeling like
that with the movies and shows like
they're all kind of doing their own
thing for the most part like doctor
strange is the most connected yeah out
of anything in other than spider-man but
uh you know but even that's going for a
different kind of movie and
ups the ante in terms of how grim and
gruesome you can get
so it does feel like yeah they're
exploring new shades even if people
think that this phase is listless in
terms of the overall you know big plan
uh yeah it's been it's i i i heard it in
and i think dan merle's reviews like you
know six marvel movies this year you
know this is like you know an example of
marvel fatigue and i was like oh
i i'm not feeling that way partly
because of what you're describing is
sort of like it seems like they are
bothering to at least try and make these
different they don't feel all the same
to me and that's part of the fun and i
think that's part of the vitality
i think the fatigue only settles in when
you don't like something yeah because if
you like something you're not gonna
you're not gonna say you have fatigue
over cause
there are people i know that absolutely
loved moon knight but then they watched
you know doctor strange and they're like
i don't like him it's like a marvel you
know so i'm like but you just said how
much you were loving moon yeah
the finale included a moon i feel like
there maybe is an expectation of just
like marvel's supposed to be great
and so if it's not great i must be
getting marvel fatigue well the i i
think the fact that they haven't made it
clear on how it's all connected even
though i trust that it will be
um i think that is
i think that
we've been conditioned for many many
movies now
to see the connective threads
and to have many things where you're not
seeing the connective threads especially
after coming off of
something like no way home
and and building up the multiverse that
much more you you would uh i think that
does that has been [ __ ] with
audiences quite a bit
so yeah it's weird because like the
multiverse you can it gives you carte
blanche to not have to be so connected
and yeah you keep wanting to see the
multiverse connector yeah yeah
[ __ ] with you it does because in the
first couple phases too people are like
oh all the interconnectivity is a little
overbearing and now people are like
where's the interconnectivity
yeah so it's it's it's interesting and i
mean yeah like after the culmination of
phase three it is a little bit like okay
they gotta kind of come up with some new
plan you know they got to come up with
what's next but i feel i don't begrudge
them having something that isn't as
obviously linked together i guess
because i do have faith right now that
they will
kind of reveal a master plan and i feel
like this being the stage one of the
next if we're going by like three stage
chunks you know it's act one of the next
chunk if that's
well
i mean here's the thing
okay i'm gonna do a little side tag here
we'll wrap up the the chat because we
should probably end this pretty soon uh
because we got other things to
definitely work on i'm gonna close these
chats but the
the
the thing i was gonna say is that
imagine with the spider-man movies
like all the spider-man was like
starting from like toby maguire if they
were really making it let's say the plan
forever was
to have all the spider-man crossover
obviously that wasn't the plan from the
beginning um but let's say it was and
then they were like
every movie was going out of its way to
hint that they were going to cross over
they were going to cross over
part of what made no way home so cool
and exciting
was they were connecting them all like a
multiverse of spider-man movies they
were connecting them all
and i think that's a bit of the vibe
that they're trying to do now
is we're not going out of our way to
shout at how it's all connecting in an
obvious way of how phase one through
three was you know build up to the
infinity stones and thanos that was very
clear and i think that's a bit of what
we're doing right now
is they are all going to connect in some
weird crazy multiverse movie the main
predictor being you know avengers secret
wars
but
what's going to make that cool when it
happens is we're going to see it all
happen was is that it's going to be that
much cooler when we see it all happen
because then because now it's like oh
they're multiple active yeah
yeah all the pieces come together the
same way no way home had that effect
and now
now they'll have that with a bunch of
different marvel movies at least that's
my expectation
and my hope for how they'll do it alex
brydes says hope the food's better in
this joint boom connectivity
leave your favorite morbius uh
post-credits scene in the chat
last of the stream labs for today from
popcorn thank you for joining in hi
y'all might not be getting streamlabs
dono's because the link has a period at
the end so lazy people might give up on
fixing it thanks john you messed up this
whole live stream uh
why does the irishman know why why does
the irishman not like the irishman i
gotta know coy
sorry we will get him to record you a
special rant
i'll have him do a one-minute thing here
one day yeah
i don't know why he doesn't what's
what's so funny is like i'm arguing with
him about this since eternals and yeah
if we don't ever go into specifics so i
actually have no clue why he doesn't
love that movie oh he doesn't like that
movie
it's gone it's just something personal
it's just me going i love it it's good
and him going it's boring it sucks and
that's all we ever
leave it at that's a perfect internet
debate that's what a lot of that is we
argue
the thing we hate on the internet yeah
yeah
all righty let's see let's see it's
crazy when phase four sarah williamson
brings up one division when it started
with one division i was like wow phase
four is going to be something truly
special and his last chunk is it can be
definitely
kind of weaving in and out
yeah something truly strong too well it
makes you wonder what the phase was
supposed to be before the world got
smushed
you know because i bet it wasn't
supposed to be exactly like this things
have been moved around in time things
have been re-cut and retooled and blah
blah
partly because of earth and partly
because of in the universe stuff
well i think there was a lot of
expectation placed on
a movie called multiverse of madness
that you would think that's when a
culmination
of madness
yeah
kinda
and then you watch everything everywhere
all at once and you're like that's a
multiverse of madness
well i mean i think with people
especially after loki and all that i
think the expectation was we'd start
seeing how how this is truly tethered
yeah
and um
it didn't quite do that
so
nor cambodge
movie could have used more runtime to
flesh out gore disagree
the second time watching it because that
was one of my gripes the first time the
second time watching it i was like i
admire
i admire who had to cut this movie down
for doing it in a way that i feel like
it could have felt a lot less
smooth to me
and the second time watching it i was
like
i appreciate and i feel like it's
appropriate the way they paced and
placed all these gore scenes i'm not
missing him too much from the rest of
what's going on however i absolutely
agree
should have more gore should have more
goring gods
uh also just like one or two this is
like one more scene of him butchering a
god yeah maybe one more scene of a god
butchering and maybe let a couple of
those monologues play a little longer or
something like that you know because
there's or a montage of him killing gods
yeah yeah
i think a
montage
and
then we would be here being like we
should go to actual scenes instead of
just a month
yeah i mean there's there's always
something man there's so much always
always the feeling of wanting more
bernie little baymax uh hey you what a
nice little sticker i appreciate it look
at that little dancing thank you guys
hey you
oni oni
i thought it was interesting when chris
hemsworth said we don't eat the children
anymore those were dark times that was a
funny ass line yes i love when they
bring in
things like that and i mean you know
it's a joke but it also does kind of
hark into you know like ragnarok is
partly about like realizing that the
past was grim and having to accept and
acknowledge that and so i thought it was
a nice call back to that theme
do they eat children in the actual lore
i i couldn't say for absolute certain
i'm not an expert but i think there is
you know something long ago once upon a
time that dealt with vikings eating
children or something like that
i feel like that sounds like the kind of
thing they would pull from a grim corner
of history and then use as a reference
mike k we got you uh alex mata calling
it now goat boats and infinity cones are
going to be new disneyland attractions i
think tyka so much has confirmed that in
in the set visit video
with the entertainment weekly or
something uh also
glad they kept sif around and that comic
accurate armor
you know i'm not as i'm not married as
sif or any of thor's friends in the way
a lot of people are
yeah that guy that guy
yeah um
uh for especially for getting a lot of
crap for that but the the sif if i
thought i was i was having a thought of
and if they killed off sif that'd be a
bunch of [ __ ] right there does it
feel like they've been and i thought
they could have used more of her too i
feel like they've been building up to
have more sif
and does she open shield does she show
up in agents of shield
once but then i mean they had her they
had jamie alexander come back uh for
that sequence in loki
and then you know they were saying how
she's going to come back in here and and
i thought they would kind of utilize her
a little bit more
and i was excited for taika ytd to have
a an interpretation or a take on her
and uh i i was not that i was like this
was my thing i'm looking forward to most
i did expect a little bit more
from her too
that's fair
justice for sif people justice for jamie
alexander i do want a little bit more
jamie alexander she's great
bow
god dumpling this is david lemon lyman
agreed it's funny for as much as people
begrudge the humor that is among the
silliest things in the movie and i
appreciate that everyone seems to love
it
it's just too adorable it's too adorable
and i love that they animated it like a
almost like a stop motion pixar
character i mean you know there's the
bow short but
but yeah
noah sunstrom that's a nice
name
i don't know how john campbell does he's
for like eight hours
i get hungry like an hour and every time
noah sunstrom what did you think of axel
i want to see more of him i liked axel a
lot i thought he uh had a really nice i
don't know i like that performer and i
thought he had a really nice back and
forth with thor
yeah i mean i think they fleshed him out
and there was something that kind of
crept up on me a little bit later on in
the film when he does say i'm glad i got
to meet my hero that seemed very genuine
seems sincere like i believe that that
moment in the story when he's referring
that to
to um
to thor specifically
so when that happened and
but earlier on in the film it seems like
he doesn't really care or like thor that
much yeah
i and uh and i thought i don't even
quite know i even know how to place it
in terms of like when did this shift
occur with the axle
or was this always part of the character
it's just he was kind of disappointed in
the way thor was behaving because you
forget that because thor had no idea who
axel was because he's been gone while
valkyrie has been running asgard
and i do that's something else in the
movie that i was kind of craving
was to see thor experiencing asgard
again
and this new version of asgard because
he's been gone for a while now
while while king valkyrie's been
building building up new asgard and i do
wish we had some of those moments of him
being acquainted with the people
especially knowing how things left off
with him
but we didn't even get that
yeah that's true that's true he just
kind of comes in asgard and everyone
listens and then yeah he rides off the
statues alan scott where's coindro he is
in the first two hours of this stream so
just rewind rewind and you'll find all
of that coy goodness
uh
tim infinity we got you
hell's swimy
in your guy's opinion with dc and marvel
can we say that villains in the movies
are really villains when riders just
make them do a whole 180 turn than they
are in the
then they are in the comics it's like
what's the point in being a villain
oh you mean when they have like some
type of character redemption or if
they're uh
saved in some way or more fleshed out
i don't know yeah i mean of the word
villain
uh implies a certain black and whiteness
i mean i feel like there's the argument
that you know it's about the character
and what the character needs and if it
suits the character to have some kind of
change but i would say that villain
often times
maybe antagonist is is a better word
because in this one gore is absolutely a
villain but he's a character with a
perspective
and a philosophy
uh and in his own mind he is doing
something good and it's it's a lot more
clear that that's what they're doing
than you know say someone who's just
overpowered and wants to break stuff so
you know i
i i think you can get repetitive and
boring though if the villains are not
fleshed out in in a way that makes them
more identifiable yeah because then
they're just punched then it's like yeah
okay we know we got to punch him and
slightly new powers and i want to
dominate you know yeah and i like that
gore's purpose wasn't to dominate but to
eliminate
a certain type of entity out there and
to liberate everybody who's living under
the thumb of all those
entities that don't care i thought that
was a really i thought that was a cool
inclusion of a villain but i i prefer
that they flesh out the otherwise it
does get
just repetitive it's the same [ __ ] over
and over again i mean i think when
you're reading a comic
a lot a lot of the time that's not to
say this is the way for a lot of
characters but but i remember even
reading like the infinity gauntlet and
and the portrayal of thanos in there you
know it's called the mad titan and and
thanos
in in the infinity gauntlet series it's
like the mad titan he's just like oh
power hungry there's so many
so many capsules
what's it called in comics with the
dialogue again that specific section
speech bubbles speech bubbles yes with
the speech bubbles it's like all caps
explanation mark said
yeah
and like that's the version of thanos
that i read
and in the movie you know josh brolin
portrays him a lot more subdued and more
internal and calm and and more
more emotional
and i think that just makes for a much
more interesting portrayal on screen
versus just another
kind of one-note straight and narrow
type of villain and so i think the path
they've been taking with fleshing out
these characters makes them more
interesting otherwise you get something
just kind of one note yeah i don't think
it undermines the point of having a
certain character be a villain if it so
happens that by the end they have a
change of harder perspective i think
their villainy is just as much about the
situation as it is about just that being
the core of who you are but it's been a
while since we've i can't when's the
last movie we've had or where the
villain is just
like [ __ ] evil
in marvel or dc or dc
i'm i'm just having a hard time
remembering i'm a little i'm a little
hungry right now i mean darkseid's
pretty much just evil and so is
steppenwolf i mean steppenwolf has a bit
of character flesh because we can
identify with wanting to please your
boss but you know i mean dark side is
pretty much just like ah
i'm mad and i'm gonna reshape the earth
i'm coming for you
yeah but you know what i mean let's not
talk like a true villain
you know i mean i mean zod's pretty just
evil
no no he's not
zod
he's just like uh
military utilitarian no zod's whole
purpose is he wants to bring back crypt
krypton
save his people okay
god someone is not a zack snyder man of
steel fan not re it's all right i gotta
watch it again
it's all right shame i like the first
why are we streaming about this
[Laughter]
uh
who else did we have what was the last
dc movie suicide squad had enchantress
uh
who is just a wiggly no one likes them
yeah i mean but that's my point is like
i kind of
who's like the last great just oh this
this villain's just [ __ ] evil
i guess zod is more about the demeanor
to me uh because he just has like a a
one kind of
don't defend it
uh yeah just evil um
that would that actually stuck i mean
it's like that's why i think heath
ledger's joker is great because
he is so fascinating and there's nothing
about him that
represents good he just wants to bring
about anarchy you know i think that's
why he's so
like that is like such
that's a great evil character like he's
evil and maniacal and i love it because
it's like there's nothing good about
this guy but they make yeah they make
they make him compelling they make that
interesting because it's it's complex
and it's hard to get a direct
understanding of motive yeah versus
no you're yeah you're just uh an angry
guy yeah with big power
you know that's a good question
hey leave it in the chat who's the last
like
maybe someone said it let's see
you get vechna but vagnet is pretty evil
um
green goblin actually is funny bringing
back willem dafoe as green goblin yeah
it was a pretty solid pick
but even he's got two sides and a
sympathy you know but goblin
is is goblin is just there's norman
osborne and there's green goblin but you
don't get them separate
i mean at individual moments yes but but
one comes with the other in these movies
i think uh
no way a home really establishes a
separation though
because he literally has to get injected
in order to get rid of the bad that's
fair yeah
yeah
starro was an evil
oh no here comes greg simping for snyder
just i've only sucked this dick once to
defend zod as a character is not
necessarily actually
being totally honest i was uh
i was looking on twitter today and i was
just like caught up in some images of
zack snyder's justice league because
they because wb announced they're going
to do a a
official digital release and i was like
[ __ ] man yeah i got to buy that movie it
was cool
it is
such a cool looking movie
yeah
and i mean yeah i think i just remember
zod as just yelling a lot i remember his
performances kind of
good but one note but uh but yeah it's
not simping
to defend the qualities of a character
and no way home treats norman as having
d.i.d it's an interesting take yeah i
can see dark elves peacemakers
peacemaker's dad isn't she he wasn't he
was just evil and was at least you know
you wouldn't want him to be the lead of
a show but he was an interesting
character well kieta you're bringing up
a riddler but even he is wronged by um
society oh yeah you totally get uh i
could totally imagine where he's coming
from yeah mephisto is pure evil
especially in his lack of appearance
thus far
uh
ned for hobgoblin yeah
i don't know i don't know do you think
we'll ever see that
ned is hobgoblin
no i don't think they got the balls
it's a challenge marvel do it
yeah peacemaker's dad that's that's a
pretty seems to be the one that's like
no it's a pretty clear-cut answer that's
a pretty solid yeah there's no like well
i get where he's coming from yeah
there's nothing i mean somebody out
there
but
i mean even like a homeland or you want
to say homelanders just evil but even
then you're you're like well
i mean they go to great lengths to
establish the apparatus that begat you
actually i get the harkness yeah
yeah there you go because yeah even
though you see her like you know try to
get killed by her own covenant at the
same time it is like
she's got a bunch of your [ __ ]
covenant
[Laughter]
oh boy all righty let's see we got we
got
the action mr 47 the action in here was
cool but looks like i'll have to wait
for god of war ragnarok to give me the
full norse gods unleashed that i wanted
here
this is this is very much like uh
a panorama of gods rather than yeah just
like norse gods in particular it would
be cool to see like the pantheon of
norse gods appear in the thor some at
some point beyond the couple that we've
gotten i really want them to do i think
they can make one hell of a god of war
movie or show i i actually i i mean it's
been a long time i only played god of
war once
like i beat the game um
and i it's been a little
while and i don't remember the details
too much
but i remember thinking there is a way
where you could definitely
streamline the story without losing the
true meat of it in about a two and a
half hour film i think there is a way to
to do that i mean it'd be everything
would be a better show when you're
adapting a video game but i think god of
war definitely
but then again i'm like just play the
[ __ ] game it is a great ass
it is a great ass video game the story
is is wonderful well that's the part of
the conundrum twos because games are so
cinematic now yes
and i mean half the cg you see in movies
is now using engines and rendering tools
from gaming anyway
um i don't know what streaming service i
like god of war to be on oh are they is
amazon doing a god of war tv series is
that is that really happening i didn't
know that oh wow
ooh america i hope they don't [ __ ] it up
damn god it's like it's that all these
game of thrones spin off
amazon's getting excited then i'm like
it's back with please don't [ __ ] it up
well yeah and amazon's got lord of the
rings too which is another one where i'm
like oh god please please have the
scripts to justify this
because uh
it's funny people were excited for it
but i feel like now no one no one's that
excited for lord of the rings um oh
they're looking to be doing it okay all
right they're looking at me doing it got
it
um yeah and you asked about uh new rock
stars why we haven't covered it's just
been
a lot of people don't and
then realize just how much
how time-consuming it can be to on the
back end of putting the videos together
and so yeah it's been like
really busy and trying not to
burn out basically is the thing to be
kind of cautious about uh from time to
time
and so just haven't covered new rock
stars in a while which is weird because
the amount of time we haven't covered
new rock stars i've become much better
friends with uh
with um with uh with eric foss like i
talk to him way more often and philip
molina both of them i'm like um
especially phillip phil and molina i'm
bear i'm very close with now and so
she's kind of funny like well
if you don't really cover their [ __ ] and
uh but now
closer friendship
don't watch the content
just connect on a human level
halo i hear terrible things
and
about
that's a real disappointing show
and i've never i didn't even watch i saw
the trailer before i'm not even like a
big halo like i haven't played the story
line that's why i never even bothered
with the trailers
um but yeah what we're trying to do is
uh
yeah we're trying to we're trying to do
i i was trying to get more movie
reactions going
if anything that's been implemented a
little bit more this year the movie
reaction stuff has been the most fun
because
i've noticed that actually weirdly
allows for more
variety
because
those tend to grow and do well
and and beyond that it allows us to
you know especially to check out more
things that we just haven't seen yet
you know like covering forest gump was
awesome like to me that was like so cool
or everything everywhere all at once you
know these aren't like comic book book
based movies or some big franchise so to
be able to cover them i was like ah this
is really fun or something as simple as
like chip and dale rescue rangers you
know
things that we normally just want to do
a review on but to be able to do a
reaction for it and then followed by an
instant spoiler review um where we talk
for like way too long uh it's great so
yeah awesome shawshank redemption is
next
uh i still gotta see shawshank
redemption mr down i'll watch your
reaction and not watch the movie
let me see here
uh
what's next here it's gorn time
we need the gore cut
20
minute more would make this a four hour
a four movie four star movie four star
movie i was like wait a minute i'm not
reading this right am i it was good to
see thor gain someone after losing so
many ps what was the purpose of having
bossed as an easter egg boss the panther
god um i think that is part of simply to
be the easter egg
i'm pretty sure i mean that whole thing
is an easter egg gallery somebody in the
chat called out the mention to the
carpenter god probably being jesus i
mean i think you see boston and coy
actually go look at that video
that we just put up uh about guardians 3
and all that stuff
um
i think
there's probably a chance that that
particular god
character will be re utilized at some
point or will show back up in context of
maybe even as soon as what kind of
forever
i don't know it seemed like of all the
things placed there that seemed like one
that could go either way but it's
probably intentional yeah
jay
tried to vote for love and thunder but
the poll glitched and i hit ragnarok
ah
we'll start a new poll just for you how
do you bucky barnes is offering to be
our moderator how do you assign someone
to be a moderator
[Music]
without them
let me see here accessing the entire
channel
uh i guess i just
do it now
all right bucky barnes this is your shot
here we go get at it bucky barnes you're
the moderator now
can you really just do that i just did
that
i guess we got another one
but you know let's see what you do bucky
barnes hold it down for the next like 10
minutes while we're here yeah maybe that
maybe that means bucky can kick the
people spamming or or you know
harvest and cultivate questions we'll
see we'll see how it goes
uh sorry jay that your vote wasn't
counted properly it's rigged
love gore talking to the kids about poor
stormbreaker being in love with a guy
who's clearly still in love with his ex
weapon
those are two separate ideas but yes i
love gore talking to the kids
i loved like as much as i love the the
quiet intensity of gore i do like that
he also got to be sort of
you know when he's talking to the kids
he's a little bigger and a little more
showy and i i appreciated the
eccentricity he brought to that yeah
he's kind of like uh like a grim fairy
tale character yeah he's like a
nightmare mother goose yeah yeah yeah
that's great
lovely choice all right bucky barnes how
do you moderate
dude do your thing
you're her little livestream moderator
hey jay
we just read your super chat jay says
moderators are able to kick people for
you so that's good go ahead kick people
oh look at that buck he's got the wrench
next everyone's just smaller everyone's
just banned these bands are real he's
been like the entire
no one's able to contribute anything
ideas
comments or otherwise
my lean 50 necro sword equals cancer
equals the villain both poisoning hosts
yeah it's a nice yin and yang for the
story
yes definitely definitely you know
um
i i think we also got to watch uh
you haven't seen tangled no
yeah
there's a whole period of disney flicks
i haven't seen i got a whole list of
movies written down
and no one's gonna care watch reactions
to those
there's a there's a few that i think
john should do solo um
you haven't seen you haven't seen fight
club i haven't seen fight club i haven't
seen the tv did you set up
though the one that you gave me i i from
like three years ago yeah i mean i have
it i've had it this whole time and i use
it but i
it my desk isn't really
big enough to accommodate it and it's
you know the room the shape and size of
the room it's a little awkward to have
the tv on the desk but i
just made the best version of that i
could
partly because for the shield finale i
was like you know what
usually
usually when i'm shooting tv reactions a
it's a testament to the shows the shows
that i watch solo are lovely enough that
it's easy to focus on no matter what i'm
watching on but usually i'm just
watching on a little laptop and usually
it's just like i've got time now so i'll
do it now uh whereas for shield finale i
was like no i want the big tv i want to
make this nice this has been a journey
so uh yeah so for movies and things like
that i i you know could probably make
that happen as well demon slayer
definitely got to happen after a
shield's done
and then yeah there are a few movies i
would happily do
fight club
face off i was going to say you should
do fight club and face off yeah
definitely boondock saints
all right that's a cult movie fight club
and face-off
seven hours tonight yeah man um
yeah i think fight club's only three
hours right
fight club is is going to be complicated
because we're going to definitely have
to work around some stuff on there um
yeah
and yeah we do uh someone just asked
lost it but yeah we uh we
we hire editing help primarily
for um
uh help with editing on the movies and
shows you know like back if it wasn't
the nerd chronic before
it was prime like john had done a couple
was primarily me who would edit the the
show stuff like and i remember doing
willy's wonderland for a movie and it's
just hard because like
this is not a disrespect it's just a
fact about like you know when we start a
lot of channels like normies or blind
wave like that's the thing that they
would always that they mainly did right
was like the the shows and movie
reactions and then like
trailer reactions mainly once in a while
you know for us we kind of like we'll
talk about movie news we'll do this and
that well we would kind of like mix it
up a while
and then um
and then so we started doing the shows
and movies we're trying to keep the
other regular stuff going too
so it's a little bit complicated so yeah
we've had to get some editing help uh
involved but
generally still pretty involved with
those as well like it definitely
wouldn't get done as quick if it wasn't
for the help that we get
uh the prepper team they're amazing and
uh but you normally how it works like
they'll send back the edit and then uh
generally one of us reviews it and that
takes a little bit of time and gives
some notes
and sometimes have to send over inserts
like for the koi videos you know if um
like a couple of them i've edited myself
like from beginning to end but sometimes
we'll hand it to them to do the first
cut and then usually it's like laying
down a bunch of markers then all those
inserts you see
grabbed by us
so it's usually like a few
one of those koi videos the common
corners like they they actually take
quite a bit of time to put together they
take a few hours and it's usually a few
people working on those
so they put
more work into those than
we do for just like tv reactions because
those take a lot of time
uh so yeah they're they're pretty
desirable those border army video essays
uh so yeah they're pretty time and then
they're usually a lot longer the first
the first the film take is usually a lot
longer and then it takes a
like it's like for the one from a few
days ago that was like
after i cut out the dead space it was
like okay this is 17 straight minutes of
koitaki i need to cut out a few minutes
of this
so and yeah that took a while to put it
together
nidak ragnarak i would love a bad movie
reaction once a month that sounds
delightful
and cloud aos stands for agents of
shield but logan b wants to know why did
odin and jane's body turn to gold dust
but heimdall frigga and his guardians
killed by dark elves and thanos had
corpses
friggin heimdall went on to valhalla too
because rules change man rules change to
serve the story they're telling at the
time and not everybody remembers exactly
what all the different moving parts of
the previous movies exactly have you
seen that thing about about uh tyka
asking natalie portman if she'd be
interested in doing a star wars movie
uh i saw the actual
video of him answering that i think
there's some sarcastic jest happening
there oh so it wasn't like he actually
forgot i don't think he actually forgot
god yeah uh
okay
eric willis cause he said it was
preluded with him constantly talking
about the movie heat and acting like
he didn't know she was in it uh okay
yeah all right so people have taken that
and run with the headline jeremy noticed
that mistake left in there
hey
that was one of the notes left for the
editor that you didn't apparently
remember
i don't know how you sent over the note
on that one where
in the video i saw it too and i was like
we got to get this up i'm not even going
to make it yeah i saw it i'm just going
to leave it
no i mean in order to make that i
watched the one you did and i did the
same thing where it's just you put the
whole no i'm saying that they left the
picture and picture in yeah yeah that
must be how they do it it was it was
weird i saw the thing and i was like
damn it also
i probably see how they edit these now
yeah you know
they probably just sync it do a picture
and picture and then follow along with
the inserts
um
but hey uh nick bethel movie couple sent
me
thank you to the movie couples movie
bunch ray they're right there the movie
couple john steve chevy has uh also been
sent by the movie couple and the movie
couple is here
yes they're the most like late but this
is actually how i hang out with people
in real life
i'm very interested i'm i'm very like i
just sit back and i'm very chill
i'm very i'm this is how i actually
interact with people yeah so the
beginning of the streams i'm like a
little more energetic and stuff with it
eventually i just get to this point now
where i'm like yep that's how i talk in
real life i'm very
very just laid back you're on in front
of camera so chilling out is just being
chill but that's not to say sometimes in
real life in a group setting i'm much
more energetic and then i kind of treat
when the camera's pointed like we're a
group setting
here we are dcf i look forward to
watching fight club with you and ben
parrish hello to nashville old mom j
movie couple
love all these movie couple shout outs
in here okay eric willem
what if eternity is used to bring in the
xmen i uh i've stopped thinking about
the [ __ ] x-men
at this point i'm like i'm just gonna
wait for marvel i'm gonna wait to be
surprised i'm just gonna wait for them
to say something because at this point
we keep theorizing and nothing seems to
be happening
um yeah like
even with even with doctor strange you
know it really it really seemed like
this is it this is the time
we had an actual we had one of the main
mutants in there
and even at least go to one time
yeah
you think that's when it's gonna happen
dj hamilton says you guys are my movie
couple now we gotta fight with wendy and
dustin we gotta fight him no wendy and
dustin are the [ __ ] they are the poop
when in a good one
i love i love wendy so much yeah [ __ ]
up um dustin is
just
wendy's friend to me
[Laughter]
um dustin is wendy's john
wendy is
so uh
at the premiere
for bob's burger
um
i got some uh
uh uh allergic reaction of food and i i
didn't think it was that bad but wendy
was like a soldier in a battlefield
hunting down security yeah um and and
help and aid
when she heard i was having and she saw
it and i was and it was i wasn't even
having that bad of a reaction but she
was so concerned that it would get worse
and she was on top of it oh and uh
john and dan cyber were with me and they
were like you're right
she found the two nicest uh on hand
medics to help she got handled
they were prepped that was one time
where i was like yeah good good on the
the
disney's 20th century people
logan b
is this how the podcasts are uh
you know we don't have just an exclusive
audio podcast right now so a lot of the
podcasts which if you guys will be so
kind as to follow the real rejects
anywhere you get your podcasts we have
uh audio iterations of the tv recaps and
reviews koi corners any particular news
items and things like that they're
probably like close to 100 podcasts up
now
um so and uh i've i've been culling some
of the backlog that'll make you know
good episodes like all ranking the
batman um so you can keep an eye out for
things like that we might at some point
have like a podcast podcast but for
right now it's uh yeah it's like you're
in the car and you want to hear you know
the breakdown of stranger things or
something like that like that's
a good place to catch up with those
things
uh
let's uh
try to wrap up this stream pretty soon
all right myleene 15. also necro sword
equals hate it's about triumph of love
over hate and death grief is love
persevering vibes
well i'm really thinking oh necrosword
equals hate it's about the triumph of
love over hate yeah
no exactly that's um
that's what i said in my non-spoiler
review yeah
was like that was a it's a that's a
theme that i'm just showing like
literally the reality shows that i've
randomly been watching i don't really
watch reality shows but i've been
getting into it lately
are things that are so love focus based
and i'm not talking like just [ __ ]
stupid shitty drama you know huh like
i'm not wanting to watch like too hot to
handle or something like that
but
uh yeah
the show the reality show i've really
been enjoying is love on the spectrum
that is i was that's a very
insightful
series
uh and i i would i would give that a
shot by the way guys it's very
informative
it seems tough it did miss chance gifts
for gold hair all right next up here
greg alba
here he is that's [ __ ] i am a
multiverse greg from earth617
oh no
i've honored whoever you are that you're
doing this and i feel so touched and now
every time you gotta come in with a
different uh profile pic and be from a
different earth
earth 619 or whatever i really
appreciate this that it's actually quite
flattering thank you
povegmeyer it was a batman begins quote
i've lost the context for what you're
referring to
i'm gonna scroll back really quick and
just see if there's a povemeier that we
could maybe refer back to but uh yeah
there oh goody
the means to fight injustice
is that it does batman begin to quote
yes
i don't remember that in batman begins
to be honest so christian bale should
have said one of his lines from batman
begins is that what you're saying uh yes
i get the joke now thank you oh yes the
comedy has landed now
these were the jokes i was hoping for in
the first half of love and thunder
comedy explained james goins or guans
damn this auto focus is kind of like
going in and out everything yeah it's
freaking out i enjoyed the movie a lot
but i had a quote hard time with the god
killer's motivations flipping and him
dying seemed rushed
seeming rushed
i could see why
both times it's worked for me and the
first time i was more skeptical but i
could understand if uh you don't
especially the urge to have it go for a
little longer and be a little more fluid
and flesh actually uh i have a question
yes how did thor know about gore's
daughter
hmm
[Music]
he talks about her a couple times and i
can't remember do you guys know what
scene
if you if he does mention her
because i don't i i don't remember when
because when he that's that's one thing
oh no i [ __ ] this up john fixed my
life he talks to the god at the
beginning and
mentions it there doesn't he
does he say it again when they're in the
eternity he says you could you could
save her you know
yeah that's a good question yeah
identity theft is not a joke
is that the person is the real name of
the person being greg alba in the chat
gym
also wendy and mom mode
everyone deserves a wendy in mom mode
get yourself a wendy and no one's
answering that question for me guys
i think yeah the monologue when they're
tied up is that when he says it it was a
sort of because i know he mentions her
to the kids and i i bet it's probably in
that scene where yeah he mentions this
to the kids in the cage but he doesn't
mention it to thor
so yeah i don't i just i guess i don't
remember the line
when he when he mentions it people are
saying that's when they're tied up in
the future
[Laughter]
and that gore guy is just absolutely
because his daughter died
and the gods didn't save his daughter
she died saddened alone
under a pile of sand okay i guess he
does i guess he does yeah he must yeah
yeah i just don't remember i just don't
recall that um
i didn't think about it till right now i
was i didn't watch the movie and be like
how does he know how did he get this i
didn't question it till right now
oh my goodness are we we're close to the
end here
we're close to the end
well thank you we are at the end bucky
barnes thanks bucky bart a hundo from
bucky barnes look you there you keeping
it 100
you keeping it 100 out in atlanta bucky
barnes moderating
and uh ash chase hiya hiya right back
what a lovely little sticker
love that little person popping out from
a cloud
it's like auntie thor thanks check out
on tv
thanks my chapters
also hey uh keep uh an eye out because
i've just received
some lovely thor themed emojis for this
youtube channel and we will have
memberships going so if you guys uh feel
so inclined no pressure you guys are
super generous especially here with
super chats and all that stuff but if
you want to become a member of the
channel keep a look out in the next
couple days there should be
a few different tiers that'll have some
fun little emojis of us as thor
characters and a little uh youtube
general discord server so if you guys
want to continue the chat even if we're
not in the room
soon you will be able yeah everyone
fight everyone fight and then hit us up
and ask us to come in
and settle the fight
on our patreon before having our page
run that was a good learning lesson to
be like you know what
you guys are adults and can handle it
it's just cool so if you want to go into
one time many hours
you just ask that you use your best
judgment and you use your most uh
consideration
we'll get uh we'll get uh bucky barnes
here bucky barnes you are on the
full-time moderation duties bucky barnes
thanks for holding down in the
[ __ ] give it up for bucky
barnes you're holding down
buddy you did it bucky barnes appreciate
you holding down the fort today dude you
and your metal arm patrick beckstead oh
my god
welcome thanks for tuning in sorry a
friend of mine from universal hi
i love all of you but i never expected
to see someone i know in the chat
uh and what camera jeremy this is a sony
a600
currently we also have a canon m6 mark
ii
and uh yes guys let's do a couple
just shouts out to the main chat really
quick
uh
if any for if everyone who had a son or
daughter die blamed all the gods things
would be rough i like that take i mean i
know i've known people who've had some
pain in their life who really believed
it
it hit me in a different way because
i've had some people in my life who who
um
believed there's a god like believed and
then have had terrible things happen
and they questioned the existence of
their life
of
why does god punish me why does god hate
me and
it that's a very fascinating thing to
kind of grow up in
because
it's not like
they don't believe god is real after
experiencing stuff and not having
prayers answered in the way they'd like
them to be
it's they believe god is real but god
hates them
and it's such a
it was it was interesting seeing a
character like gore here which
the pers people i'm thinking of are not
you know like gore the god butcher but
it is like that's a real thing that
people go through
there is a very real emotion that
there are people who who really go
through that and uh yeah feeling like
whoever your chosen higher power either
hates you or doesn't care at all is
ambivalent towards you but you know like
i'm talking like there are people i know
who it was like a daily thought and
thing they struggled with like all the
time so it's just fascinating
to know that no they're people who
really have that
way of thinking yeah
it's hard to become a [ __ ] atheist
i had friends yeah i take responsibility
for your life
i've known some people who get into that
position too and it's funny because
they'll i i knew a couple people who
would have this this way of sort of
renouncing god as if to suggest they
were an atheist but the way they would
talk about god
was very much from a place of anger for
certain traumatic events that had you
know taken place and it was one of those
weird things of of almost the paradox of
being so upset at the idea of god that
you
do both you're like god's not real
but also like i hate god and f you know
like all these things as if
you haven't let go of the idea that they
are an existing thing
yeah um i don't know i don't know how to
articulate that but uh on that note he
says
there we go when they're tied up he says
i had a daughter once choose love call
the axe so he says it to jane apparently
that's good ah
yes now
right when you laid that out i heard it
in my i i i remember that on now yeah
remember the shot too yeah yeah oh okay
that's true call the axe
yup yup yup
well alrighty guys and so in that moment
thor was like that's why he's killing
the gods
because
you put it on see thor's not some new
little buffoon
he put it all he put it all together
right there i'm lost says the batman is
so much better i think these are
comparable films
the batman and thor love and thunder
they are
absolutely toned for the same thing
totally but yeah guys we definitely
should wrap it up there's some things we
gotta handle over the next few hours
here but thank you to everyone who
participated uh today um thank you
everyone who contributed to the super
chats as well that always means a lot
y'all are lovely and um go follow koi on
tick tock
thanks to bucky barnes for holding down
the stream
and uh yeah
all righty well
we're the weird notes and on but we've
running here we're done it's over thank
you guys thank you for being here we'll
talk with you all soon and uh yeah
peace and love peace love and thunder
love
and rock and roll
thank you